Hallo.
Von den.
Teige drohnen und tote gar nicht es ging um bahnen und boote den kongress mit all dem was da so wahr kommt und ist nur in einem dreißig passt das.
Ich bin gespannt ob wir heute wieder vier stunden fünf vierzehn hinkriegen mit mehr toten ja da bist du ja ein garant taler.
Nein nicht ganz ich habe noch niemanden selbst getötet.
Das ist meine klare ansage naja es kommt kommt halt kommt irgendwann kommt das an,
wenn ich unmittelbar dann vielleicht man weiß es ja nicht ne schmetterlingseffekt cetera all diese ganzen geschichten es passiert ja schnell.
Ja ja total.
Ja freakshow nummer zweihundertvier zweihundertzwölf vier sechs zweihundertsechsundvierzig ist jetzt heute euch mal datum sagen neunundzwanzigsten januar zwanzig zwanzig vergisst das ja immer manche leute finden das wichtig,
ist wahrscheinlich auch wichtig aber ich vergesse es dann trotzdem immer und heute haben wir eine kleine runde metaller,
aber dabei haben wir es nicht dabei belassen wir's nicht genau aber alle anderen sind trotzdem nicht da deswegen haben wir gregor eingeladen hallo.
Hallo guten abend.
Hallo gregor wann warst du das letzte mal da.
Vom jahr ja kongress nachklapp.
Okay das ist wirklich ein jahr her.
Du hast den tim vergessen wir müssen doch den tim vorstellen.
Stimmt genau ich war so im prinzip mach mal.
Wir haben den tim der ist wie immer da.
Bus genau der ewige tim des mal da das stimmt.
Denn schon mal eine freakshow ohne dich weil ich weiß es gibt bei logbuch netzpolitik gibt's das ja manchmal dass du auf reisen bist und.
Das stimmt genau.
Aber eine freakshow ohne dich müsste doch technisch möglich sein.
Ja vielleicht.
Das freak niveau wäre dann zu niedrig.
Nein das darüber möchte ich mich gar nicht auslassen,
keine ahnung also ich meine an mir hängt dann doch so die produktion im wesentlichen und ist ja manchmal auch schon schwer genug die runde zusammengetrommelt zu bekommen es gab zumindest mal eine fliege schon nur mit mir,
damals als es noch mobile exil ja das wollte ich dann aber auch nicht nochmal machen.
War das genau vier stunden fünfzehn minuten.
Nee ich glaube eine anderthalb guck mal kurz das war die home lounge sendung das ist allerdings auch schon zehn jahre her ich bin alt.
Gab's da wenigstens den begleitschutz noch oder war das wirklich monolog.
Sie hatten wir das damals überhaupt schon ich glaube ich glaube da waren wir noch nicht so konsequent live oder doch ich weiß es gar nicht mehr,
muss mal kurz gucken doch doch doch da wurde auch schon gestreamt und dann müsste es zwangsläufig eigentlich auch noch ein,
das ist eigentlich auch noch ein dazu gegeben haben ja.
Aber den vorgänger mobile max gibt's doch schon ganz schön lange noch zwo sechs zwo sieben acht dann fing das an.
Das fing an acht oder warte mal die erste war genau erster april zweitausendacht ja das heißt es werden dann im laufe dieses jahres zwölf zwölf jahre gewesen sein.
Jetzt die laufende nummerierung bezieht sich auf die mobile max folgen oder ist das fing es mit freakshow mit der umbenennung neu an.
Nee fing es nicht an wir haben einfach weitergezählt in gewisser hinsicht ist ja also die kontinuität sollte schon da sein und es ist ich weiß nicht ich betrachte diesen ursprünglichen namen immer noch als unfall.
Aber hat längere zeit getragen.
Ja das hat hat in mir die düstere erkenntnis mitgeliefert dass die leute dann sich von einem schlechten titel nicht abschrecken lassen.
Wo ich ja nicht mit gehe also also ich fand es wirklich durchgehend als doof und ich weiß gar nicht wie lange hat es gedauert bis wir das.
Jahre freakshow gibt's seit zwanzig elf zwölf so in etwa.
Warte mal also die erste war oh gott,
also hundertvierzehn genau also hundertfünfzig war die erste dann friedhof,
aber schon mehrere jahre vorher.
War das dein interner.
Stank mir der name so nee ich war auf der suche ich war auf der suche nach dem richtigen namen und wie das eben manchmal so ist,
es braucht dann so seine zeit und dann war es aber auch irgendwie klar und dann war es irgendwie auch so der name der schon hätte immer sein soll.
Vielleicht auch können aber das war ja dann auch wiederum am anfang nicht so ganz klar wie diverse sich das hier alles verzettelt,
ja da sind wir jetzt auf jeden fall ne,
ich dachte mir ich schiebe das dann gleich mal vom tisch damit damit ich die schwierige thema gleich gleich weg habe aber terry jones ist gestorben,
warum ist das jetzt ein tote genau
warum ist das jetzt ein schwieriges thema nicht weil ich jetzt in totaler trauer versinke das tue ich in gewisser hinsicht auch wenn man auch sagen muss das war für ihn wahrscheinlich eher eine erlösung zu dem zeitpunkt
aber ich habe gerade im vorfeld dieser sind festgestellt dass offensichtlich hier niemand mein humor teilt.
Ich hatte so ein rtl samstagnacht moment.
Was ist das für eine art moment.
Da bringt sie war so eine deutscher klon von city nightlife in rtl und in den neunzigern und da haben sie immer so eine nachrichtenshow als teil,
ihres gesamtprogramms gehabt und da wurde immer ein ein toter eingeblendet und den aber niemand kannte,
und es war immer dasselbe foto immer so ein bisschen schwarz-weiß und dieser effekt dass man als normal zuschauer,
irgendjemand ist gestorben und in der regel neun von zehn fällen kennt man die person gar nicht,
und dass dieses gefühl dass da also quasi eine ganz bedeutsame person gestorben ist von dem man nie vorher gehört hat jedenfalls aktiv nicht gehört hat das wurde quasi da immer auf die schippe genommen.
Aber es waren schon richtige tote.
Nein nein nein natürlich nicht das ist ja die haben einfach es,
weißt du es war auch ziemlich unlustig muss ich trotzdem schwächste aber vielleicht ist das auch ganz gut hinsichtlich meines verhältnis terry jones also unlustig halt auch ja so und,
hätten die einfach gesagt harry jones ist tot hätte ich es hieß jones ist tot und dann hieß es ja der
bekannte britische comedian ist in den siebziger jahren bekannt geworden durch seine mitgliedschaft in der spaßtruppe monti breiten,
in etwa wurde das dann eigentlich da hat's dann bei mir klick gemacht aber das war's dann auch also ich hatte kein bild von von dem mann,
deswegen war das.
Kennst du die anderen von monty heißen.
Ja diesen diesen einen der fisch nimmt damit gespielt hat das ist der.
Du kennst noch ein.
Dieser clack oder wie heißt er.
John clean.
Den meine ich.
Grad wird jetzt wirklich hart ich hoffe das ist schon klar dass jetzt wahrscheinlich ein großteil unserer hörer schafft sich schon so der magen leicht verkrampft.
Ja aber das das ist ja.
Schon wieder mit diesem blick an mit bei dir wird es nicht besser ich weiß nicht.
Ja die freakshow also dieses dieses dieses freak ist ja ne und dieses gefühl das kriegen jetzt die zu zuhörer jetzt auch mal wieder dass sie da jemanden mitbekommen.
So jemanden gibt es außerhalb der bubble.
Dass es sowas geben könnte doch wir sind voll im thema von toppic der freakshow.
Ich sag dir mal die anderen namen ja,
genau terry gell.
Ja der.
Amerikaner in dieser truppe.
Der ist auch glaube ich so der einzige der so ein bisschen gut über das ding hinweggekommen ist.
Ich finde die sind eigentlich alle ganz gut über das.
Terry jones nicht.
Weil er jetzt gestorben ist oder was.
Nein aber ich habe dann erfahren dass er auch demenz hatte und schon schon lange krank ist und also dem ging es dann nicht so gut.
Die letzten drei jahre ja genau.
Ja aber wie gesagt hat jetzt außer ein fisch namens wanda mit clean finde ich hat terry williams so eine ganz eigene reputation als eine,
bekannter wichtiger science-fiction regisseur entwickelt,
der ist also quasi über dieses ich sage jetzt mal die spaßtruppe hinaus gewachsen das ist ja so als otto walkes dann arthaus reputation erlangt hätte.
Ich bitte dich also monty preise auto walkes in einem satz das geht gar nicht da hinten ist dein das das geht nicht.
Das geht total weil weil otto walkes ist ja quasi das verkündet organ gewesen von der titanic die gesamte ja jetzt jetzt schaue ich dich aber an.
Das verkündet okay erklärt.
Die gesamten jones alles auto walkes ist nicht lustig der ist ein,
ein präsenter alles was jemals also außer diesem gekichert und uns seinen grimassen hat otto walkes nie was selber gemacht sondern das hat er sich alles von der neuen frankfurter schule das ist so ein comedy truppe,
die ist verbunden mit der titanic viele davon sind inzwischen auch alles schon tot aber otto walkes ist ja auch nicht mehr so jung,
und die haben quasi zum geld verdienen ihre ganzen witze und auch so sachen wie das motto buch und so den ganzen anarcho humor quasi auf otto walkes gekippt,
und.
Du meinst wir waren die aktiven autoren und zu träger wusste nicht das erklärt dass das ja.
Dass es so gut war und das ist hinterher so schlecht wurde in dem moment wo.
Mir zugetragen haben.
Ja weil bei diesen filmen haben sie ja nun erkennbar nicht mitgearbeitet würde ich mal sagen.
Die filme waren quasi ein teil meiner kindheit.
So haben wir jetzt den nächsten street spot.
Nein nein alles gut aber das ist tatsächlich also
kinder humor betrifft das halbwegs auch wenn ich wahrscheinlich damals einen großen teil nicht verstanden habe aber meine eltern haben glaube ich relativ viel von von otto walkes gehabt und dadurch bin ich damit so ein bisschen,
aufgewachsen deshalb kenne ich den mehr als manipulierten.
Und dann.
Da solltest du aber dran arbeiten ich meine ich fand jetzt seine ersten filme auch schon noch recht lustig also sie waren gar nicht so schlecht.
Es ist einfach es gibt halt diesen otto walkes sketch mit den organen und.
Oh der ist wirklich gut kommt ja auch von der frankfurter schule.
Das weiß ich nicht jetzt wann welche zu trägerschaft aber im prinzip ist,
dass sein autoren kollektiv gewesen wie harald schmidt ja auch nicht seine witze selber oder böhme seine witze schreibt das sind alles das ist ein ein ein team und du hast einen präsenter den stellst du raus
in dem fall war das so ein kollektiv ob jeder von denen jetzt titanic zu träger war der da mitgeholfen hat das weiß ich nicht nur,
ich meine jetzt dieses spielfilme die dann otto der otto der film also alles andere war ja wahnsinnig anarchisch in dem sinne dass das jeweilige medium komplett,
verhauen wurde otto das buch war alles als ein buch das war quasi.
Das hat irgendwie das internet so das wird so so so einen block irgendwie das internet vorweggenommen total klitzeklein hin und her und du bist ja durchgegangen und hat sich selbst auf die schippe genommen und sowas als film,
das wäre natürlich genial gewesen aber,
das haben sie nicht gepackt sondern haben gesagt wir machen jetzt hier so eine art rahmenhandlung und dann wird dann quasi so ein paar ottos ketchup die man alles schon so kennt an der richtigen stelle platziert und diese handlung hatte überhaupt keine erkennbare,
relevanz sondern das war ein träger schiff für für die schon komplett ab
gehangen otto performances wie zum beispiel schwarz braun ist die haselnuss war dann entsprechend den michael jackson zöller video mit heino wieder gänge.
Das war eben sich schon lustig aber es wäre lustig gewesen diesen spot einfach für sich,
zu nehmen und dann wieder was total anderes rauszuhauen aber nicht zu versuchen so eine konventionelle geschichte zu erzählen und das meine ich das hat,
für mich otto dann gebrochen weil die otto show zum beispiel die gab es nur einmal im jahr,
das war alles andere als eine show es war einfach nur wild und er hat ja aber so jetzt bringe ich ein lied und das und da hatte die gitarre weggeschmissen das heißt es ist eine ankündigung geblieben also,
ich glaube,
genau ich glaube es gibt aber diese adhs wissen will was ich glaube da musst du einfach nur die autoshow sich doch mal angucken diese aufmerksamkeitsspanne ich singe jetzt ein abtreibung,
adios.
Das war dann in den filmen und wird jetzt auto und die sieben zwerge und wasser jetzt seit vierzig jahren alles macht das ist nicht der otto mit denen ich aufgewachsen bin das war einmal im jahr gab es diese otto show und das war,
das war wirklich dann ein tag nachher im schulbus absolute das gespräch und dann fand ich ja schon sehr cool wenn ihr so die älteren ja aber letztes jahr fand ich irgendwie besser.
Naja also dieses maß an mangelnder kreativität das kann man multipresse nun wirklich nicht vorwerfen insbesondere nicht was ihre filme betrifft,
und schon gar nicht was so ihre sketch betrifft ja also für mich ist die preisen auch eher so ein phänomen wie loriot.
Mario dann bin ich auch nicht so alt verstanden ich glaube der ist auch sehr überbewertet.
Haben wir tim tim nicht weinen also ich wird gut.
Ich überspringe das jetzt mal kurz auf jeden fall warum ich das gerade gesagt habe ist so auch loriot hatte so in diesen siebzigern für so eine ein paar jahre,
mit seinen mit seinen sendungen mit seinen switchen mit seinen shows alles rausgehauen und es war ja sozusagen definierend für alles was danach kam dann kam noch ein paar filme und so die.
Von diesem selben team die otto schon in den abgrund in den kreativen gerockt haben man war derselbe produzent das ist ein wendland horst wendlandt der story ist schon tot
wenn nicht dann bitte ich um entschuldigung.
Kann schon sein aber das hat ihn ja nicht daran gehindert dass die filme dann auch noch ganz gut waren also die pussy et cetera fand ich dann doch sehr gelungen aber vielleicht liegt es auch nur daran dass ich.
Dass du jung warst.
Dass ich einfach auch mit schwanken im im lori so,
zurück zu multipilzieren um das mal gebracht haben also ich finde abgesehen davon dass man die preise für das ganze internet ja allein schon deshalb stil bilden ist weil sie uns den begriff spam gebracht haben,
also ohne ohne diesen spam sketch wäre hätten wir ein anderes wort für spam.
Kannst du den spam sport nochmal kurz für für die nicht monty breiten also für für mich ich weiß es dass es das gab aber ich habe die.
Es ist so.
Wort nicht verstanden und ich habe auch nie verstanden.
Es ist einfach so ein crazy sketch wo leute im restaurant sitzen wo dann ich glaube übrigens auch wieder terry jones ja weil er immer diese verrückten mittels gespielt also frauenrollen sozusagen also,
wie heißt es so schön männer in frauenkleidung wieder gibt's noch so.
Was heißt travestie.
Ja ich habe gerade ein anderes wort gesucht wie auch immer auf jeden fall das hat er immer hervorragend getan
und gerne wohl auch und also erst mal so eine renitente restaurant köchin besitzerin anführerin chefin und die leute fragen halt was es gibt dann halt so die speisekarte vor alles enthält irgendwie spam,
also es gibt irgendwie social spam spam potatoes bam bam.
So jetzt muss ich nochmal als unwissende spa was ist bam.
Das ist gekochtes dosenfleischprodukten.
Das ist es der gegnerische begriff oder ist das der der markenname des anbieters der dosenfleischprodukten.
Es ist der markenname.
Das muss man natürlich woher soll denn das normaler mensch denn wissen dass das quasi so wie wie tempotaschentücher ist das ist das tempo.
Spice ja.
Das ist eine abkürzung sowie bella.
Weder räder.
Radio action.
Ja wie viel es man ist es ein akronym.
Das wusste ich nicht deswegen.
Ja spam ist dosenfleischprodukten ist übrigens eine der erfolgreichsten produkte nahrungsmittel produkte die diese welt je gesehen hat gibt's ja auch heute noch und.
Bam hat gar nichts mit fleisch zu tun sondern spam wurde spam weil es quasi in dem sport so über über präsent und nervig.
Genau darauf wollte ich gerade hinaus also sie ließ halt die.
Jetzt weiß ich da muss terry jones erst sterben damit dieses mähen jetzt mal für mich.
Ja ja ja also.
Haben die nicht auch so extrem flug einwurf werbung gemacht die die spam hersteller.
Flug einwurf werbung was ist das.
In den briefkasten so zeug so so analog werbung spam.
Wer hat das gemacht die firma.
Ja ich dachte.
Vielleicht kommt daher der der witz mit dem spot dass der quasi in der realität eine.
Nein nein nein nein damit hat es eigentlich nichts.
Zwischen archäologie.
Ich kann da ist es ist kurz genug man kann das mal einspielen.
Das ist die mutti heißen die erkennungsmelodie ihrer ihrer shows.
Und das ist dann halt dieser heißen sketch da sitzen sie an alle in diesem restaurant alle als wikinger verkleidet.
Gäste fliegen von oben herein.
Balken,
sophie,
super entspannt,
dienstag noch,
stammen,
spanien kopf balance,
und das.
Spaß
und wie ein bei den spannungsbogen ja wie oft willst
hammer wenn's spannend sparen sparen sparen,
mensch.
Ich war einfach so empirisch verstehst du.
Musste jetzt auch lachen.
Ja weil dieser sketch ist einfach da ist einfach gott ich weiß gar nicht wo ich anfangen soll das war jetzt also wirklich wieder terry jones ja in dieser frauen rolle dass dass es so würde ich sagen eine von,
zwei drei sachen die ihnen extrem definiert haben abgesehen davon dass er halt auch der regisseur von lebendes brain war,
brian ist würde ich sagen das beste was man die preisen überhaupt je gemacht hat und definiert eigentlich alles wofür sie stehen die ganze religions und gesell.
Bis auf diesen fight des schwarzen rütters gegen diesen anderen ritter lädt finde ich besser.
Dritter der kokosnuss achso ja gut.
Aber nur diesen fight weil der.
Der ist auch toll ja klar natürlich also monty python holly grail ist steht jetzt auch noch mal für sich auch multipresse sind des lebens ganze neue zusammenstellung ihrer sketcher etcetera.
Mein problem ist auch dass ich das ja alles nur in deutscher übersetzung.
Deutscher nein ach bitte.
Ja ja ja ich komme aus aus einer anderen welt ist nicht so nicht so internationalistischen überflieger tum wie du ja.
Ich bitte dich internationalistische.
Wieso du kommst auch aus hannover ihr seid ja praktischen teil des vereinigten königreichs soweit ich weiß müsste jetzt ja aus der bundesrepublik demnächst austreten wenn großbritannien die eu verlässt.
Genau übermorgen geht's los.
Hannover was auch immer.
Also du.
Weißt du wer noch schuld ist.
Bin jetzt ich bin jetzt schon zufrieden du hast du hast ein,
du hast gelacht du hast ein sketch du hast gesehen die jungs haben power so und es ist einfach und alle und das mag ich auch so daran,
alle in dieser truppe sind einzeln wert sich genauer dass man sich genauer anschaut
also michael pellen hat hervorragende filme gemacht der missionar und diverse andere sachen schon dieses werk ich meine ohnehin der superstar von
monty python nicht.
Weil der auch so super britisch ist.
Weil er auch einfach wie soll ich sagen also alle hatten alle waren mit ihrer performance außergewöhnlich aber john clean hat einfach auch immer wieder total auf die spitze getrieben so.
Und jetzt müssen wir aber noch über alfred biolek sprechen.
Der ein großer förderer von multipresse und freund war ja.
Ich glaube da waren die gerade hatten ihre bbc show vielleicht für ein jahr also im ersten jahr ist der schon hingekommen hat gesagt ich will euch nach deutschland bringen aber ihr müsst es natürlich alles auf deutsch dann machen,
es könnte sogar sein dass sie quasi dann,
dinge ausprobieren mussten weil sie nicht so weil es sonst lost in translation verblieben wäre und dass sie dann noch mehr situations komik und einfach silly walks ausprobiert haben weil das,
ist auch für deutsche dann ohne sprachkenntnisse des englischen also deutlich.
Also alfred biolek mag da eine eine erhebliche katalytischen rolle gespielt haben,
aber ich glaube dass die truppe auch an sich extrem beseelt davon war sich so mit deutschland auf so spezielle art und weise auseinanderzusetzen.
Und menschen die brexit.
Genau also,
zitat thomas also das ist halt diese fernsehserie von von john clean dot menschen also alleine diese eine folge von wo die deutschen zu gast sind und er so als chef dieses kleinen hotels irgendwie völlig durchdreht und
immer so dieses so the germans coming dort menschen so war das kind alles völlig,
es explodiert einfach alles so und und das ist das ist diese kraft dieser truppe gewesen die damals auch in großbritannien eine eine totale revolution waren und das halt dann eben auch weltweit die haben einfach humor,
auf einer auf einen auf ein level in dieser ganzen präsentation in diesem wahnsinn gebracht,
gab's so vorher nicht also es ist einfach zeitenwende.
Und interessant ist auch diese grafik stil von denen das war allerdings auch so ein breiteres ding sie haben ja immer diese kupferstich.
Diese animation mit dir alle mit diesem gezeichneten das war übrigens ne.
Das sind alles so sachen die zu diesem thema vintage und vintage bbc heißt ja deswegen vintage nicht weil es weil es,
hat was mit der zwanzig zu tun also vintage ist also was aus den zwanzigern es war quasi so eine ende der sechziger,
anfang der siebziger ja so eine rückbesinnung auf die wilden zwanziger jahre und das wurde dann auch bei der papers loony harzklub band ist sie selber statik schon aufm plattencover zu sehen
und das scheint so in dieser späten sechziger anfang der siebziger jahre so für mehrere jahre so ein
zumindest aus meiner sicht in england besonders stark verbreitetes ja kulturelle folie gewesen zu sein die die alle ausprobiert haben auch
auch die kostüme der rockstars zu der zeit alle sind sie in die flohmärkte gegangen und haben halt so dieses dieser stil wurde ein highlight vintage also rück bezüglich auf die zwanziger jahre bezogen und wird heute
für alles was alt ist benutzt also ein vintage computer ist er jetzt.
Du willst mir jetzt erzählen das wort vintage hat was mit zwanzig.
Lisa vintage.
Es kommt aus den zwanziger jahren also ein vintage computer ist kein computer aus den zwanziger jahren des neunzehnten jahrhunderts.
Von der uhr bedeutung her sowie das wort mal eingeführt worden ist bezog sich auf eine nostalgische retro idee auf die zwanziger jahre,
und jetzt mal breiter bezogen auf die vorkriegszeit weil natürlich der zweite weltkrieg dann so ein sowieso eine so ein einschnitt war,
in deutsch würde man jetzt eher sagen hätte man jetzt nicht vintage gesagt sondern vor kriegs irgendwas vorkriegszeit.
Also ich muss zugeben dass ich mehr über über die.
Ja ein bisschen was muss ja hier auch irgendwie was neues.
Hallo.
Ich muss ja auch was lernen.
Ja gut aber vintage heißt eigentlich weinernte also das ist sozusagen der der ursprung des wortes weinlese.
Dann bin ich dann bin ich total falsch informiert worden weil ich das von den zwanzigerjahren gehört habe.
Ich finde es eine schöne these ich frage mich nur gerade ob die ob die sich auch irgendwie stabil mit mit mit mit mit quellen füttern dass sie finden nur gerade kein aber vielleicht kann das ja der chat an der stelle.
Wir verfolgen das mal nach vielleicht ist es ja auch ein wortspiel aus.
Ist auf jeden fall eine schöne schöne these aber bleiben wir vielleicht beim humor so also taler was mit dir du du kannst mit manche du hast auch noch nie guckst ja immer nichts.
Ja ich glaube ein ein problem ist tatsächlich dass ich nicht viel konsumiere an und das andere ist monty python ist für mich halt auch schon über zehn jahre her also.
Ist für alle über zehn jahre her weil das ist ja alles schon dreißig oder vierzig jahre her.
Aber,
ich war halt damals irgendwie keine ahnung wenn ich als ich das erste mal mit mandy peißen in berührung kommen war ich vierzehn oder so,
und dann gab's halt natürlich nur die sachen auf deutsch und das was mir irgendwie freunde gezeigt haben aber seitdem ist in meinem leben einfach so viel passiert dass da nicht viel übrig geblieben ist,
es wird tatsächlich glaube ich mal wieder zeit das nochmal zu gucken.
Das würde ich aber auch sagen bevor sie alle gestorben sind.
Das macht glaube ich für mich keinen unterschied ob die jetzt nur noch leben.
Doch es hat den unterschied dass wenn dann wieder jemand stirbt in dem moment auch weiß wer da jetzt gerade gestorben ist und was das sozusagen.
Das habe ich halt auch.
Mentale auslöst.
Nee das habe ich halt auch gerade gemerkt ich glaube ein ein anderes problem ist was ich habe ich,
namen sind halt einfach einen namen ja ich kann mit dem namen nichts anfangen und das ist wirklich relativ selten dass ich eine person irgendwie am namen wiedererkenne.
Gut aber vielleicht erkennst du ja filme an an ihren namen wieder wenn das nicht hilft kann ich auch nicht sehr viel zu beitragen aber auch vielleicht für dich noch mal dann können wir das thema auch gerne einstampfen es gibt also monty preisen,
die preise circles war ja so dieses show-programm was sie in die bb reingebracht haben.
War das dann vorher schon irgendwo in den clubs am laufen oder haben sie das für die babys.
Die waren
ne die waren also so alle freier autoren schreiberlinge waren auf die eine oder andere art und weise manche kann sich ein bisschen länger schon andere sind dann auch erst in dieser neuen konstellation zusammengekommen da gibt's irgendwie tausend dokumentationen die das alles haarklein wiedergeben das kriege ich jetzt auswendig auch nicht mehr so ganz zusammen aber im kern war es so
dass eben mehr oder weniger durch so ein zufall sie eben in dieser lage gekommen sind bei bei diesen slot zu füllen
und dann im wesentlichen auch so ein bisschen davon gezerrt haben dass sie das in einer ja zu einer zeit machen konnten wo so.
Sie erstmal eine weile machen konnten so,
und noch nicht so wie das heute ist gleich nach der zweiten sendung wo die einschaltquoten und wir hauen da mal drauf und sie waren halt vom start weg haben sie eigentlich mit allen regeln gebrochen
und haben einfach einen style dahin gebracht und ein humor der einfach so bissig und so satirisch und und kritisch von allem war ja und jeder kriegt er sein fett weg politiker
die kirche legenden nichts philosophen dichter denker alle
alle kriegten auf die glocke niemand wurde in irgendeiner form verschont
dazu waren sie halt alle extrem gute performer so sie waren einfach on point und hatten einfach einen humor ich könnte jetzt ich könnte jetzt so eine lange liste von sketch raufbringen wo jeder
einzelne für mich
irgendwie immer wieder eine zeitenwende eingeläutet hat ja also es nimmt einfach kein ende und für mich persönlich wo wir dann immer wieder von jugend prägung,
reden waren dann eben auch die akteure von monty auch auf.
In anderen bereichen extrem prägend so und das fängt halt für mich vor allem an mit dem film brasil kennst du den.
Du kennst natürlich brasil warum natürlich.
Ich glaube der kommt auch aus den achtzigern da gab's nicht so viel da ist man noch in jedem halbwegs jeden film reingegangen wäre.
Okay von wem ist brasilien.
Na von william.
Ja genau unter anderem spielt dort michael payne mit auch einer von monty preisen,
den designer rolle hieß check lindt der dir diese folterung in dem kühlturm gemacht hat.
Es gibt doch so zusammenfassung von filmen in tweet länge dann ist es doch wahrscheinlich ein fliegenschiß verursacht,
konsequenzen der bürokratischen nachbearbeitung.
Hallo.
Für bürger eines fiktional staatswesen in.
Das ist jetzt nicht mehr twitter konform.
Hundertachtzig.
Zweihundertachtzig zeichen.
Hätte.
Ja aber der film,
brasil ist einfach mein lieblingsfilm ist einfach der wird auch von nichts jemals überholt werden können weil die zeit sich einfach nicht wiederholen lässt oder aber das war auf jeden fall ein meisterwerk und mike paddeln spielt halt mit,
robert de niro spielt mit.
Man erkennt ihn nur nicht.
Wen erkennt man nicht.
Also ich weiß dass es der klempner ist der super mario ich überlege mir ob auf super mario vielleicht nach nach brasilien entstanden ist.
Laub.
Weil die idee so quasi sowas,
zum crazy klempner als als die idee einer so widerstandsreihe ganz kraft die ist so verblüffend und auch so nah am echten leben.
Wann gibt's denn super mario mario.
Super mario brothers.
Also seit wann gibt es mario als.
Aber genau das dürfte vorher sein.
Als figur.
Ich würde mal sagen fünfundachtzig und ich sage brasil ist dreiundachtzig vierundachtzig rausgekommen sein.
Fünfundachtzig ist brasilien rausgekommen.
Mario ist einundachtzig ist mit donkey come first experience.
Also verbreite hier lauter lauter.
Aber vielleicht ist es auch anders rum ja.
Mario.
Genau,
ja also ich muss ja jetzt nicht mehr so sehr.
Also es ist in jedem fall also für mich ist es ein sleeper weil ich habe am anfang natürlich wieder überhaupt nicht verstanden und fand ihn weil er so unterwelt rigs und,
wie gesagt über über die jahrzehnte wächst der film und ich glaube wenn ich ihn heute mal sehen würde würde ich wieder,
erheblichen mehr verstehen und mehr von der relevanz und signifikanz dieses werks erfahren können.
Das sind ja die tollsten filme die man sich fünf bis sieben mal anguckt und dann hat man das gefühl dass man jetzt langsam versteht worum es da überhaupt geht.
Ja also wer immer schon nicht wusste warum man sich mal die peißen anschauen sollte jetzt bist du es vielleicht.
Und es gibt auch keine begründung warum der film brasil heißt zum beispiel das ist ja auch das ist ja ein bisschen mit der überschätzung von titeln und namen.
Das stimmt das stimmt.
Aber das lied gab es schon oder wurde das dann nachträglich noch der titelsong.
Brasilien nein das das gab's schon vorher das ist ja schon fast gar nicht von von von von was von wann dieser film eigentlich diese dieses lied eigentlich ist aber das.
Ich würde den auch zutrauen dass sie quasi so einen auf nostalgischen gemachten song was.
Brasilien der englische und internationalen titel des brasilianischen liedes dobra sil.
Neunzehnhundertneununddreißig.
Ich sage nur wintertage.
Genau in einer gekürzten form wurde unter dem englischen titel brasilien international bekannt also walt disney neunzehnhundertzweiundvierzig in seinem film saludos amigos,
auf deutsch drei kavaliere im sommerfieber verwendete oh mann.
Na ja wow.
Wieder was gelernt.
Darfst du auch zwölf monkeys.
Oh den kenne ich.
Also territorium hat viele großartige filme gemacht also das da war brasilia nur der erste.
Er hat ja auch das mit john williams als ritter im central park gemacht ne.
Fischer king kündigt der fischer ja genau da kamen einundneunzig.
Der hat ja also ich würde mal sagen der hat eine richtige rausgewachsenen hollywood karriere gemacht und für mich so ein bisschen.
Vier und losing in las vegas ja.
Von telegram wow der film ist lustig.
Das ist einfach ist einfach ein ein ein ein ein held der,
von allem möglichen großartiger typ so und die können noch so,
wie sagte dann zum tod von tariflohns down to go,
sie zelebrieren das was übrig ist auch extrem empfehlen kann ist die.
Wie soll man das nennen also andacht ist irgendwo falsche bezeichnung aber als das erste mitglied gestorben ist nämlich graham chapman der ist ja schon ende der achtziger gestorben das war derjenige der den brian in leben des bryan gespielt hat also den,
quasi den jesus so gibt's eine großartige session findet man auch online
wo halt die anderen fünf von monty python sozusagen seiner gedenken
aber halt so in der besten body peißen manier wie man es sich nur irgendwie vorstellen kannst
sie halt einfach über ihn hergezogen sind und wie sie lustig gemacht haben nur nur so glaube ich hätte auch graham chapman das erwartet und ja
da ist dann auch vor allem das sind auch immer so die momente wo john wirklich immer zur höchstform aufläuft und ich denke,
wenn es ihnen dann mal erwischt dann dann ist das geschrei richtig groß weil er ist halt irgendwie mit abstand die die populärste figur geworden aber auch alle anderen auch,
eric eitel den wir jetzt noch gar nicht genannt haben sind alle für sich einfach hervorragende performer und tolle lustige typen an ich habe gerade die letzten wochen waren wieder viele,
interviews auch angeschaut wo die dann irgendwie alleine oder zu mehreren sich irgendwie über peißen kram unterhalten,
einfach extrem unterhaltsam.
Ich habe eine komplett andere assoziationen wenn du sagst leute unterhalten sich über pfeifen.
Ja die habe ich auch manchmal nur jetzt gerade eben.
Ja ich weiß konnte er ist aber.
Immer dieser kontext ja apropos wir werden alle sterben teilweise einblick ob ob wir jetzt eigentlich alle sterben werden.
Sowieso immer und überall früher oder später es geht ja grade so ein bisschen ein neuer virus um oder ein ein alter virus der.
Ist er so alt.
Die der der korona stammen da gibt es mehrere varianten von,
ist irgendwo glaube ich bei wikipedia ganz hübsch aufgelistet und die mutationen diese zweitausendneunzehner motivation gibt's auch schon.
Anfang zweitausendneunzehn oder so.
Corona virus ist ein familienname eigentlich ne für eine virus gattung und von daher ist die aktuelle diskussion der of the trails weil es alle von dem corona virus reden aber eigentlich ist es die klasse von viren.
Ja aber es geht gerade um eine konkrete mutationen.
Davon ja aber sowie saß und und so weiter das waren.
Genau genau.
Auch eine davon gewesen aber nur diese mutter hat schon um die es jetzt gerade geht die hat jetzt gar keinen namen.
Doch das ist aber irgendwie.
Kennt ihr bloß wieder keiner.
Ja irgendwie vor neunzehn irgendeine abkürzung von neunzehn.
V neunzehn.
Ja
Okay die große gefahr,
die lage ein müssen wir uns jetzt eingraben.
Na das spannende an viren ist ja entweder sie sind schnell tödlich und dann bereiten sie sich nicht so weit aus,
oder sie sind infektiös aber im normalfall hochinfektiös aber im normalfall nicht so schnell tödlich,
das problem wird eigentlich nur dass dass diese viren halt sehr schnell mutieren können das heißt wenn man ein virus hat was,
ziemlich schnell sich ausbreitet wie aktuell dieser korona virus mutationen,
und der sich dann irgendwann entscheidet ich möchte jetzt mal tödlich werden dann haben wir tatsächlich ein problem,
aber jetzt gerade ist das noch harmloser als eine normale grippe in dem sinne also einer normalen grippe und in der grippe saison sterben deutlich deutlich mehr menschen,
als bis jetzt am an dem corona stamm genau da oben steht dass zweitausendneunzehn.
Tv
Genau es gibt eine super schöne karte von der ich glaube johns hopkins,
wo so ein bisschen dargestellt ist wie viele bestätigte fälle ist gerade in welchem land oder in welcher religion region.
Religion das um sich greift.
Genau und tatsächlich sind die todesfälle noch relativ überschaubar was es,
was aber so ein bisschen das auch wie bei der normalen grippe eigentlich schwierig macht ist wenn leute,
denken sie müssten krank zur arbeit gehen oder sie müssten krank einmal in ein anderes land einreisen und das ist dann eher grob fahrlässig denn wie bei,
anderen viruserkrankungen man kann sich nicht also man kann sich auf bestimmte stämme impfen,
deshalb jetzt sehr grippeschutzimpfung und die ist auf jeden fall für so die typischen risikogruppen ältere lungen vor erkrankte kinder,
immer schwierig und die werden halt auch einfach zuerst sterben.
Was die impfung ist schwierig.
Nee nee die der der virus ist schwierig für diese.
Was ein älterer wenn ich das schon.
Geriatrische personen werden ab fünfundsechzig offiziell eingestuft.
Puh gregor wir sind gerade noch mal von der schippe gesprungen.
Diplomatische antwort raucher oder generell lungen geschädigte,
haben halt einfach probleme ja also das größte risiko ist tatsächlich einfach die leute die krank unter menschen gehen,
mit irgendwie infektiöse krankheit sich in die notaufnahme setzen zur arbeit gehen auf dem flughafen in ein anderes land einreisen und so weiter.
Bist du denn schon grippe geimpft worden in diesem jahr.
Ich war auf dem kongress natürlich habe ich mich davor grippe impfen lassen.
Ja ich hab's leider nicht geschafft.
Also das ist zu empfehlen es muss sich nicht jeder grippe impfen lassen.
Wir müssen nur genug sein.
Es müssen zum einen nur genug sein es müssen vor allem die gruppen die halt viel mit risikogruppen in kontakt sind also lehrer gesundheitspersonal leute die vielen kontakt mit,
älteren personen sind die sollten sich auf jeden fall impfen lassen weil das halt auch diesen dieses infektionsrisiko für die gruppen verringert das ist dann einfach,
gut ansonsten wäre so eine richtige grippe ist schon echt nicht schön hatte ich zum glück auch noch nie.
Ich glaube ich auch nicht woran merkt man denn das dass man eine hat.
Also wenn du glaubst du stirbst dann hast du vermutlich eine grippe,
also der grippe sind wenn man eine richtige grippe hat dann ist es wirklich schlimm so mit fünf tage im bett und nicht bewegen und man denkt wirklich.
Es geht zu ende.
Das ist eine grippe.
Hatte ich noch keine.
Es ist gut so ist gut so.
Ja sehr gut finde ich super ehrlich gesagt.
Es kann dann halt schnell schlecht werden.
Aber warum wird er nicht so viel über diesen corona virus geredet wenn eigentlich die grippe vor der tür ist und ja irgendwie millionen leute weggerannt und keiner diskutiert drüber.
Weil das halt einer dieser stämme ist gegen dies zum einen keine impfung gibt der sich gerade sehr schnell ausbreitet,
und wo halt noch nicht glaube ich abzuschätzen ist wenn's halt eine eine motivation gibt,
dann kann es halt auch schnell deutlich übler werden als eine grippe und das ist sind jetzt so schutzmaßnahmen.
Aber was weiß man denn ich meine es sind denn jetzt schon leute daran gestorben und das in nennenswerten zahlen also ich meine.
Neuer paar hundert.
Echt so viel.
Gestern waren's noch zwohundertachtzig.
Da oben rechts hundert hundertdreiunddreißig sind bestätigte bestätigte todesfälle und das sind im prinzip halt die risiko patienten.
Hundertsechsundzwanzig haben sich auch schon wieder eingefangen.
Genau das sind meistens die jungen gesunden.
Okay.
Wo dann halt keine viren last mehr nachweisbar ist.
Ok aber hundertfünfundzwanzig dieser hundertdreiunddreißig tote sind alle in dubai rheinland china also es ist wahrscheinlich diese provinz wuhan von der oder woran ist der stadt ne,
woran ist eine stadt keine ahnung kevin nicht ausreichend aus in china muss sagen aber überhaupt handelt viel berichtet.
Eine stadt wahrscheinlich mit so viel einwohnern wie die niederlande.
Kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
Mindestens ja.
Sind auf jeden fall viele menschen auf engem raum.
Also ich denke mal da ist auch ein gewisser fokus auf china weil china so als die neue kommende superkraft sich darstellt da wird jetzt genau hingeguckt,
wie die mit so einer krise umgehen wenn derselbe fall in kongo stattfinden würde dann hieß es naja bürgerkrieg ebola dies und das elfenbein
berggorillas und jetzt haben sie auch noch eine grippe dann wäre das überhaupt keine nachricht aber hier geht es quasi um die die zukunft,
der bär ja die zukunft der weltherrschaft wenn sie das ding richtig wuppen,
sie machen sich glaube ich in china da auch richtige gedanken drüber im vergleich zu dieser saß geschichte das haben sie so ein bisschen runter gespielt,
ich könnte jetzt sein dass sie sogar im umkehrschluss ein bisschen über vorsichtig handeln,
um damit aber auch legitimität hinsichtlich ihres staatlichen handelns zu gewinnen wo sie sowohl,
außen aber auch in der bevölkerung selber gibt es da ein misstrauen trotz allem.
Ja also es hat halt alles wie immer zwei seiten ist es
relativ cool dass sie jetzt in kürzester zeit ein neues krankenhaus aus dem boden stampfen oder zwei,
arbeitsbedingungen der arbeiter und menschenrechte die dort verletzt werden schwierig diese komplette,
krankheitsstand und prävention auch als argument zu nehmen irgendwie wärmebildkameras in öffentliche gebäude zu hängen und dann einfach alles rauszufischen was irgendwie ansatzweise fieber hat die dann im nachhinein noch nicht abgebaut werden,
auch so ein bisschen.
Das habe ich quasi im prinzip,
mit andeuten wollen quasi da ihr gesellschafts-und zukunftsmodell ja gewissermaßen auch von so einem überwachungs- mantra geprägt ist,
würde es natürlich mit einer erfolgreichen eindämmung dieser krankheit auch eine legitimität,
wiederum nach innen und nach außen bringen so nach dem motto seht mal was ihr uns alles vorwerft hinsicht totalitären überwachungs- mechanismen sieht mal wir,
tun das alles zum wohl unserer menschen,
und kritisiert uns bitte nicht dafür deswegen hat es aus meiner sicht quasi neben diesem ganzen solchen,
aspekt der natürlich immer bei solchen ereignissen,
relevanz hat nochmal eine besondere relevanz weil's china ist und wie gesagt wenn es ein anderes land wäre von mir aus argentinien dann würde das nicht.
In dem maße präsent sein es kommt noch hinzu china ist und das sieht man jetzt ja die lufthansa hat alle flüge nach china unterbrochen
sehr viele der internationalen handelsvertretung werden jetzt ja gerade dadurch so richtig evident weil wir basti in bayern es ist halt eine schulung von einem chinesischen mitarbeiterin die dazu geführt hat dass die ersten
bekannten und und verifiziert,
ansteckungen in deutschland eben durch diese globalisierten handlungs-und ströme entstanden sind und,
anhand dieser geschichte merken auf einmal diese verflechtung und integration die china mit der gesamten weltwirtschaft halt schon hat und dadurch wird es so ein mega thema das aber einfach auch,
für china wahnsinnig wichtig ist für die für die nächste zeit ob sie es quasi so eine art zivilisatorische soft power entwickeln im sinne von wir kriegen die dinge gewuppt.
Guter punkt ja und ich glaube den anspruch haben sie aber auch das gewuppt zu bekommen,
also dass sie das ja schnell,
hoch fahren können das haben sie glaube ich wirklich gezeigt in der letzten zeit und es wird interessant sein zu sehen wie sich das entwickelt aber ich hätte jetzt auch nichts dagegen wenn sich das erstmal weiterhin auf asien konzentriert.
Naja es ist halt die frage.
Oder überhaupt nicht mehr konzentriert.
Ja es ist halt die frage wie wie hoch quasi diese es gibt ja paar patienten zero,
patient null sozusagen und dann je nachdem wie gut sich das weiter verbreitet von ja irgendwie exponentiell,
kann das halt ganz ganz spannend werden also das ist auch,
gar nicht so trivial irgendwie zu modellieren wie sich denn solche,
solche ausbreitung tatsächlich entwickeln weil das von so vielen faktoren abhängig ist und einfach auch wie sich dieses virus dann nochmal entscheidet,
also ob es weiter bei tröpfcheninfektion bleibt oder ob es plötzlich mal zehn minuten länger an der frischen luft aushält das macht halt schon einen extremen unterschied wie viele quasi sekundär infektionen auch wenn's das falsche wort ist,
dann passieren.
Weiß man jetzt eigentlich schon wie die infektion läuft also.
Tröpfcheninfektion.
Das weiß man okay.
An hosen an nächsten es gibt einen sehr lustigen beitrag vom postillione ein zum zum corona kann ich sehr empfehlen da werden alle fragen die irgendwie aufkommen beantwortet.
Aha das hier.
Glaube ich ich gucke mal.
Auswärtiges amt kündigt ein deutscher aus bayern auszufliegen das meinst du nicht.
Es ist ein gut gute das ist ein guter doch.
Ach nur weil's gegen die bayern geht.
Nein ich glaube da da liest du drüber und ich hatte das jetzt im ersten moment für eine philipp auch für eine wahre meldung erhalten musste erst nochmal drüber nachdenken wo da der der kicken ist.
Warte ich muss mal kurz in den speck durch diesen fragen und antworten wo kommt der name her wie gefährlich ist es,
wie wird's übertragen.
Aha okay sehr lustig ich erzähle jetzt wird's aber hier nicht alle nach.
Nein das kann man.
Es könnte ja alles in den shownotes nachlesen genau.
Was bei dieser ganzen seuchen geschichte mir immer wieder klar wird ist,
normalerweise immer so einen überwachungs- und polizeimaßnahmen diskurs in der gesellschaft haben aber dass wenn,
die politik irgendwann sagt jetzt ist solche,
dann können so dermaßen drastische persönlichkeitseigenschaft maßnahmen adhock durchgesetzt werden dagegen sind alle,
hallo,
emanzipatorischen diskurse der letzten vierzig jahre wirklich pillepalle und das steht alles relativ klar seit ewigen zeiten seit,
zumindest seit man weiß dass es viren und bakterien gibt und wie die geeigneten maßnahmen da aussehen können und die werden auch nicht nicht nicht angegriffen ich glaube,
auch das ist jetzt wieder so eine diese idee,
pass auf deutsche verhältnisse oder europäische verhältnis mal umzukehren zu ja also im ruhrgebiet hat es der erste fälle geht wir werden jetzt mal das ruhrgebiet.
Ab riegeln ja das sind so die dimensionen die in für uns,
überhaupt nicht politisch vorstellbar sind die dabei jetzt auch wieder zu dem was ich vorhin gesagt habe jetzt,
halt durchexerziert werden liegt man quasi so eine große menge von bevölkerung einfach mal von,
von der durchlässigkeit und von der integration integration zur welt einfach abgeriegelt.
Ich muss da gerade so ein bisschen an zwei sachen denken das eine ist es gab mal in den achtzigern irgendwie eine serie wo eine gruppe von personen wir wohnen löcher in so parallelwelten,
gehopst sind weil die eigentlich auf ihre eigentliche welt zurück wollten und da gab es tatsächlich eine folge wo penicillin nicht erfunden wurde.
Und dann hat man halt genau danke und,
da hatten die halt das das das problem das patient siro gesucht wurde von,
ich weiß nicht erkältung grippe oder so und das war dann halt auch innerhalb der folge irgendwie rausgekommen dass ja diesen patient siro gab es aber diese komplette,
maßnahmen oder dieses komplette aufbaust der der erkrankung war eigentlich irgendwie von der regierung aktiv,
provoziert und irgendwie dieses erkältungsviren aktiv freigesetzt weil man wollte irgendwie bevölkerung reduzieren und da muss ich irgendwie immer wieder dran denken die zustände die dann auch da einfach,
existiert haben und dann kam halt diese leute und meinten so,
ja aber warum stell dir kein penicillin her so hier schimmelpilz und guckt mal da und hier gegenmittel,
das war total lustig aber das andere die diese extreme absicherung ist halt auch irgendwie bei resident evil,
richtig.
Da kommt man ja relativ schnell dann in solche zombieapokalyptische.
Zombie und dass das irgendwie alles immer nicht funktioniert weil menschen halt menschen sind und ihre freunde retten wollen und dann ist es plötzlich doch überall.
Ja gut aber du versuchst natürlich erstmal das öffentliche leben für die neunzig prozent der anderen aufrecht zu erhalten dass die nicht alle aus dem haus laufen und sich mit äxten weil der jüngste tag ist da gegenseitig nieder.
Da und panik.
Ja es geht auch darum dass quasi die geregelten strukturen und macht konstellation handlungs-und,
bereit und handlungsfähig erscheinen,
und damit auch weiterhin ihre legitimität nicht angegriffen wird und insofern ist das jetzt schon recht interessant weil die legitimität bestimmter staatlicher gesellschaftlicher institutionen ist sehr stark angegriffen das,
hört man ja von von ganz vielen seiten her,
angriffe auf die feuerwehr im einsatz die angebliche respektlosigkeit gegenüber polizeibeamten und,
jetzt die sache mit den kommunalen meistern die jetzt alle aufgeben,
weil sie aus den sozialen und nicht so sozialen netzen heraus beleidigt bedrängt und.
Ich glaube die gucken alle sehr gespannt gerade wie das,
momentan so läuft und gucken glaube ich also es wird das ist meine
meinung in wenigen tagen wird es in irgendeinem struktur konservativen leitmedien so eine so ein kommentar geben wenn die wenn die chinesische regierung das so halbwegs in den griff bekommt hat so nach dem motto das jahr
hier hat gewissermaßen das totalitäre zentralistische,
autoritäre system seine legitimation gegenüber der welt bewiesen ja und welche konsequenzen muss dann der freie liberale westen,
daraus ziehen und daraus wird dann jemand schreiben mehr autorität wagen und das deswegen ist es auch ein super spannendes thema weil über diese,
lebenswichtige geschichte,
ja alles zu subsumieren ist oder die frage ausnahmezustand das war ja quasi das wo da die achtundsechziger gegen aufbegehrt haben das war ja so quasi der,
initialphase moment sich überhaupt gegen die damaligen strukturen aufzug dagegen zu wehren.
Die diskussion könnte nochmal wieder unter ganz neuen bedingungen der heutigen öffentlichkeit und ja und so halb öffentlichkeiten und ihrer macht und einfluss richtig spannend werden.
Ich glaube es wird tatsächlich auf jeden fall gerade gern genutzt so als ablenkungsmanöver
endlich passiert mal wieder was neues und nicht nur klima und wir werden alle sterben sondern hier jetzt gibt's eine konkrete bedrohung und die einen wollen halt eher so don't panic alles gar nicht so schlimm und die anderen nutzen das halt als,
wir haben jetzt hier ein neues thema und klima ist plötzlich gar nicht mehr so spannend aber.
Also endlich mal eine katastrophe ohne klima.
Na ja so ohne klima nee da stecke ich nicht genug in der materie drin um jetzt oder andersrum.
Von der von der öffentlichkeit in der wahrnehmung struktur ja es könnte jetzt auch ein erdbeben sein können also das hat nun mal nicht mit dem klimawandel zu tun dass die erde beben.
Man könnte sogar so argumentieren hätten wir erstmal siebenundfünfzig grad auf der erde gäbe es das wären problem nicht mehr.
Da warte ich ja nur drauf.
Bilder nicht muss nicht sein.
Aber du hast ja hier noch was interessantes gefunden.
Ja ja ja ja genau wir wer selbst mal die menschheit ausreden ausrotten möchte,
aus retten ausrotten es gibt seit ein paar jahren die wunderschöne app blake,
wo
mit erstaunlich viel wissenschaftlicher simulation im hintergrund tatsächlich das ziel des spieles ist die menschheit auszurotten indem man ein virus bakterium
was auch immer so genau mutieren lässt das halt möglichst,
die menschheit ausgerottet ist das heißt alle infiziert alle tot und die,
ki des spiels sorgt halt zum einen dafür,
dass man so heilmittel dagegen entwickelt wird dass die wie das,
wie das virus zum beispiel spray dann beeinflusst wird also es ist irgendwie übertragbar nur durch berührung oder durch luft.
Kann es kann es über wasser zum beispiel sekundär kontamination verursachen und,
das ist tatsächlich so gut gemacht dass diese modelle die dort hinter,
hinterlegt sind inzwischen halt auch einfach mit durchgelaufen lassen werden wenn man so ein so ein virus abschätzen will wie wie es sich verteilt wie quasi,
yo logisch sich auf der auf der welt ausbreitet.
Der chat hat ja auch gerade ein statement von black also von der also halt blackie heißt die firma oder die app die app heißt so.
Die app heißt so genau.
Genau und also die hersteller der app meinten halt so na ja immer wieder wenn's dicke viren attacken gibt dann merken sie das
gehäufte anfragen auflaufen und sie weiß noch mal darauf hin dass sie sich nicht unbedingt aber als so sehr sie das ganze
informativ und realistisch versucht haben hinzubringen dass sie dann trotzdem nicht möchten dass die leute jetzt ihre app als referenz nehmen oder daraus ihre informationen oder ihrer
handlungsanweisungen ableiten.
Nein bitte nicht wie er app irgendwelche viren motivieren lassen.
Tja na ja gut aber.
Aber es ist ganz spannend und unterhaltsam und man kann selbst mal ausprobieren.
Wieso ist die welt ausrotten.
Deshalb mehr tote.
Hallo.
Oder oder auch um das zu vermeiden.
Ich liebe diesen mobbing unterton die diese nummer bekommt wenn du dabei bist.
Um das zu vermeiden gibt's da ja einen schon ziemlich,
gut abgehangener instrument das der quarantäne und weil ich vorhin bei der vintage ja so irgendwie ins schwimmen geraten bin bei quarantäne bin ich mir ganz sicher das kommt von vierzig
zwar dass man für vierzig tage in so einem moment gesteckt wird und,
dann ist man entweder tot oder gesund und kann dann wieder auf die noch lebenden wieder losgelassen werden.
Wenn ich's richtig im kopf habe kommt das von den von den schiffen die würden die würden vierzig tage lang einfach auf see gelassen und er wäre sind dann alle tot oder die dürfen an land gehen.
Diesmal ist recht also hier wird explizit also sagt wikipedia,
über das abgeleitet von galopp romanisch karamell über das volkslauf abgeleitet von lateinisch quadratmeter quadra ginter für die zwei vierzig oder eben vierzig tage,
zusammen wird ihm zugeschrieben.
Ok wir werden alle sterben an der an der stelle vielleicht nochmal der hinweis auf lars fischer großartigen wir werden alle sterben kanal wo er sich auch geäußert hat zu.
Fisch fisch block oder ist das fleisch fisch blog.
Fisch block da schreibt er darüber aber er hat halt jetzt auch konkret zum corona virus auch noch was beigetragen ich werde das hier auch gleich nochmal in den,
chat so bald.
Das war eigentlich so ein briefing das war kanzler runden verdächtig ne so wenn die regierung so wissen will.
Was phase ist.
Lars fischer wird,
die morgenrunde eingespielt.
Genau der kann sich auch gerne über die tätlichkeit der parteienlandschaft noch irgendwie zu äußern.
Ich finde die quarters extrem gut gewählt ja sind ja auch sehr niedlich.
Gut wie geht's eigentlich mit deiner mit deiner apple fixierung voran wir hatten das ja hier letzte mal.
Peißen läuft.
Damit ist dann alles gesagt.
Damit ist ich bin tatsächlich.
Also wer es nicht gehört hat hat er hat jetzt einen weg.
Ja ich hab status-update.
Wir sind schon aufkleber dran.
Sowieso immer muss ja tada fixiert werden ähm.
Digitaler finanzierung ok.
Ja ja,
im prinzip das meiste wofür ich's gerade nutze ist tatsächlich peißen gibt und irgendwie normale kommunikation also über diverse chat programme,
wie ich kommuniziere was mir,
bis jetzt gerade tatsächlich am meisten fehlt es irgendwie mein not plus plus,
das ist ein sehr schönes windows tool,
was eigentlich ein gegnerischer texteditor ist was viele plugins hat für verschiedenste sprache unterstützung aber für mich ist es tatsächlich so meine standard notiz-app.
Also es wird das als sourcecode-basis verwendet also ist das jetzt so wie die so ein mächtiger texteditor.
Ja auch ne ja es ist es ist es ist ein ziemlich guter texteditor der auch im prinzip unterstützung für code highlighting hat und,
verschiedene plugins um halt auch code formatierung vorzunehmen und ich mag,
dass tatsächlich ganz gerne bin ich halt inzwischen auch so ein bisschen mit mit groß geworden und da muss ich einfach noch eine für mich funktionierenden ersatz aufm weg finden.
Jetzt rauschen natürlich schon die texteditor vorschläge rein es.
Wird dann auch alle nach und nach durch evaluieren.
Von welchen hast du denn schon gehört weil ich meine mackintoshs hat natürlich auch so seine eigene vergangenheit von großartigen text-tools.
Ganz ehrlich ich hab noch gar nicht so weit geguckt sondern ich gucke erstmal wie weit ich mit onboard gerade komme.
Wie on board ist nicht nein das kannst du komplett vergessen.
Ja das habe ich auch festgestellt dass das nicht das ist was ich möchte.
Nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein.
Aber ich habe mir tatsächlich noch nicht die zeit genommen für die manko oder die die fehlenden sachen die ich jetzt für mich identifiziert habe alternativen zu finden ich bin jetzt erstmal noch in dem stadium,
zu evaluieren was was brauche ich überhaupt was fehlt mir gerade und das ist halt das eine,
da muss ich dann in ruhe mal gucken ich bin dem chat jetzt schon dankbar dass er bleiben.
Es gibt ja es kann ja gleich noch was zu sagen es gibt es gibt eine,
nahezu unendliche liste von wirklich sehr etwa texteditor.
Wahnsinn texteditor ja.
Frage ist so ein bisschen,
welche geschmacksrichtung einem sozusagen letztlich am meisten liegt nahezu alle die jetzt hier gerade genannt wurden ich kann gleich nochmal was dazu sagen ich kann doch jetzt nicht alle in und auswendig aber zumindest die meist schon mal ausprobiert
am ende ist es immer so ein bisschen geschmacksfrage alle haben,
eine menge zu bieten also alle haben bande und eins und natürlich die ganze sourcecode-basis realisierung und was nicht alles.
Die sache ist ich nutze ihn ja tatsächlich auch nicht zum kurven sondern ich nutze ihn primär für,
pretty fing also.
Na gut das ist ja.
So ab und zu mal und ansonsten nur einfach für für notizen schreiben und tatsächlich wenn ich von
excel zum beispiel
daten formatieren muss und die irgendwo anders reinhauen weil nordpark plus plus hat halt so multicar funktionalität die für mich super intuitiv ist,
und einfach funktioniert und dann kann ich halt eine table reinhauen irgendwie die tabs durch kommas ersetzen oder andersrum und gehe dann mit meinem multi corsa durch und schreibt noch irgendwie in jede zeile,
irgendwas rein und kopierst dann wieder raus und woanders rein also.
Multi curser damit meinst du in mehreren stellen gleichzeitig reinschreiben etcetera ja die funktionalität gibt's auf jeden fall auch.
Bestimmt das ist einfach nur ich muss halt muss halt gefunden werden.
Muss halt gefunden werden also was hier genannt wurde dass ich würde sagen muss auf jeden fall,
b ist so der text editor klassiker überhaupt auf den macintosh,
den gibt's jetzt schon seit zwanzig jahren oder so also es ist richtig ausgewachsene stabiles zeug dann gab's so mit der rubio rails welle gab so ein neuen,
schwung an an texteditor angefangen hat das mit text made.
Ich habe nur gerade nach b geguckt und gleich google erster untertitel quasi zu erster treffer ist das gut ja.
Sagt genau das ist das ist unser motto seit anfang an,
und das sind alles sehr abgehangener hacker die wissen was sie tun so also das ist auf jeden fall ein klassiker und das lief auch schon,
auf dem alten und es halt in die neuzeit mitgeführt worden und wird also am laufenden meter aktualisiert hat sehr zufriedenstellend release note etcetera,
dann text made war so dann die nächste revolution und ist halt wie bibi endet halt so also so native app,
was beim texteditor nicht ganz so wichtig zu sein,
scheint ich persönlich habe immer so ein bisschen meine probleme wenn du diese ganze cross-plattform artige entwicklung in apps rein gießt da gehört dann auf jeden fall so so bleiben mit,
in dieser nummer.
Das ist nochmal für mich so ein bisschen ja.
Die haben alle auf jeden fall immer eine xxl ring the bell weil das habe ich auch,
das problem habe ich auch öfter so also es ist für mich war so vorliegen also dass man wirklich strukturierte daten aufmacht vor allem dass die dinger mit großen dateien keine
haben aber dass wir eben bei xxl auch nicht nur so ein so ein british hast sondern eben auch so.
Highlighting und ein und ausblenden und.
Ausklappen also der ganze kram das muss irgendwie alles ordentlich funktionieren so also die würde ich mal testen es gibt da noch eine ganze reihe mehr aber ich denke da bist du auf jeden fall schon mal ausführlich mit beschäftigt.
Und das einzige okay ja b edith kostet muss ich dann noch mal gucken.
Ja aber kann man auf jeden fall irgendwie testen et cetera.
Ja ja das ist ja.
Gute software kostet geld.
Not bad plus plus kostet kein geld ist halt auf spendenbasis ja es ist es ist einfach ja es ist halt einfach.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht ist auch nicht schlimm es braucht einfach nur zeit und ich das größte manko ist halt ich habe zwei aktive betriebssysteme wo ich,
einen großen teil meiner software nicht auf beiden nutzen kann oder zwei lizenzen kaufen muss und das ist jetzt auch für mich einfach noch so eine sache,
was möchte ich wo haben was nutze ich wo vielleicht bleibt der mac auch einfach ein schlankes system und ich nutze es primär für peifen einziges problem was ich da noch so ein bisschen mit habe,
bei bei der nutzung von gilt habe ich mir halt angewöhnt irgendwie nur git sternchen punkt und dann dateiname endung von von allem was ich quasi hinzufügen fügen möchte,
das geht unter aber nicht unter mack einfach nur kit sternchen punkt zum beispiel,
das kann er auf dem terminal auf dem mac nicht aufblühen aus gründen auch immer.
Wer kann das nicht auslösen.
Das terminal kann das nicht auflösen welche dateien ich dann meine.
Nicht dass terminals macht ja die shell.
Oder kann es nicht kann es nicht auflösen wenn ich das so schreibe in kombination mit habe ich,
einmal kurz recherchiert und es hieß wohl irgendwie ja du musst es anders machen und dann dachte ich mir so nee jetzt nicht,
also da muss ich halt auch nochmal gucken entweder schreibe ich mir irgendwie makro was wohl geht oder ein alias was das besser auflöst.
Ich bin gerade vollkommen,
vom kopf gestoßen was da nicht gehen soll ich meine wenn wenn irgendwo wildcards funktionieren dann da wo sie herkommen nämlich nix.
Tja ich kann's dir gerne nachher zeigen ich habe gerade leider ein kleines system wo alles eingecheckt ist.
Sternchen oder sternchen und dann meint er halt sternchen punkt de kann ich nicht finden.
Lösungen die ich jetzt für mich temporär gemacht habe ist zweimal tappt drücken und dann löst er dir halt das sternchen quasi auf und haut ihr dann alle.
Stell dir punkt muss expandieren was passiert wenn du echo sternchen punkt party machst.
Wie gesagt ich kann's gerade nicht testen ich habe ein kleines system ja.
Du hast doch trotzdem die pfeils darum liegen wenn du echo stern punkt palmas.
No matches found sternchen punkt aber ich bin halt auch in einer überordnen nicht in einem.
Ja kein wunder dass es nicht findest und muss.
Aber unter windows geht's.
Wie unter windows geht er findet findet datei die gar nicht in dem aktuellen ordner sind.
Ja sondern in den unterordnen.
Stern sternpunkte.
Und genau das ist der unterschied.
Oder unter der bisher vollkommen branded sternpunkte auf den fulda geht dann ist das geht irgendwie anders.
Ich sag ja nur das ist gerade der unterschied und meine best practice oder mein mein standardweg war jetzt einfach nur ich bin in irgendeinem überordnen und sage geht sternchen und dings.
Verstehe die wildcard wird auf windows von dem kind selber ausgeführt und dann macht er das irgendwie anders und nicht von der shell oh gott also ich weiß nicht damit will ich mich gar nicht mehr weiter beschäftigen okay gut na also wenn das das scheint ja dann doch irgendwie ja,
sehr spezifische probleme zu sein.
Das ist halt alles so was im prinzip einfach mir auffällt.
Im wesentlichen also alles gut.
Ich bin ja auch nur dümmste anzunehmen der jusos ich mache hier nicht viel mit dem system ich bin ich habe noch nicht die zeit irgendwie in in fancy spielerei,
vorzustellen aber es es tut was es soll.
Apropos dümmste anzunehmende user ich wollte euch von einem erlebnis von einem living so future moment berichten weißt du was ein living moment ist.
Absolut also wenn man ihn überhaupt erlebten kann dann am ehesten in deiner gegenwart.
Soweit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen aber.
Deine ersten podcast noch als rasende reporter auf einem udo,
so rundgang da hast du irgendwie so leute interviewt und als einer deiner,
schüler studenten aus der digitalen klasse glaube ich oder ist gekommen und er war vermutlich schon leicht euphorisiert durch welche substanzen auch immer und hat einfach nur reingeholt,
mensch lebt in der zukunft und alles was er macht das ist unglaublich und dem müsst ihr zuhören dass es tim.
Ich habe gesagt ich kann mich gerne daran erinnern.
Ich weiß nicht müsste eigentlich in das müsste eigentlich so der.
Nee das war french war das.
Vielleicht ist es ja irgendwie noch archiviert.
Ist es ist es ist es ist es definitiv also ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Solltet ihr mal reinhören das ist einfach so toll weil die,
diese unterstellte begeisterung für all das was den tim so ausmacht von jemandem der,
in dieser späten stunde jetzt auch nicht mehr bezahlt oder abhängig vom tim war da jetzt irgendwie zu flattern das kam so aus dem herzen heraus.
Wie ist denn das ding irgendwie,
ich kriege es raus auf jeden fall mein mein living future moment war jetzt nicht,
vielleicht nicht ganz so weltbewegend aber es ist halt einfach immer dieses ding wenn man irgendwas das erste mal macht und es ist halt irgendwie,
es hat irgendwie so ein bisschen was mit zukunft zu tun in diesem fall war es eine hotel buchung aber gar nicht so sehr die buchung selber sondern mehr das ankommen an diesem hotel,
wollen wir mal wieder klar wurde es geht so ein bisschen voran und zwar war ich in in leipzig in einem hotel mit dem zauberhaften und vielversprechenden namen mac dreams.
Ja so ähnlich habe ich auch geguckt aber es war in dem moment das hotel genau an der richtigen stelle genau da wo ich es brauchte zum zeitpunkt zum preis und so weiter es hat halt irgendwie alles gestimmt und ich dachte mir was kann schon schiefgehen und habe mir das dann halt mal irgendwie gebucht und geklickt.
Ein bisschen wie die japanischen love hotels.
Also ich kann vorspulen es war alles okay mit dem hotel.
Die japanischen laufe holz sind auch total schick haben sogar lustige sieben rooms.
Da kannst du ja dann gleich nochmal von berichten.
Ich kenne sie nur von außen.
Achso nur von hörensagen sozusagen ja.
Wenn du an der straße stehst und eine riesengroße center winkt dir entgegen so in drei meter größe dann fragst du dich was ist das santa claus.
Center.
Und dann guckst du und stellt fest ja es ist ein weihnachtszimmer lauf hotel wo man stundenweise weihnachtszimmer räume buchen kann.
Ok verstehe ah hier ist die sendung tl null null zwei ja das war in der tat wirklich einer der,
allerersten sechzehnten februar zweitausendsechs na ja auf jeden fall war ich da eingebucht und bin dann halt irgendwann dahin gefahren und wollte halt einchecken hatte es relativ eilig weil ich eigentlich mehr oder weniger auf dem sprung zum fußball war,
und also eilig nicht im sinne von es kam auf sekunden an aber ich wollte jetzt nicht so viel zeit mit dem einchecken verbringen,
kann da irgendwie an mein vater so mit dem fahrstuhl hoch und ich sah halt erstmal so eine schlange von
vier bis fünf personen die alle irgendwie in diesem check-in hessel drin hängen und wenn man das so kennt bei hotels wenn erstmal eine schlange ist so,
kann lange dauern ich dachte mir so,
und dann stand ich auf einmal neben so einem gerät und dachte mir so was könnte das wohl sein und stellte fest es handelte sich um einen check-in computer.
Weiß was hast du da war mich einzuchecken und ich finde das irgendwie mal kurz an kurz nachdenken sag mal so,
was ist eigentlich so kompliziert irgendwie an einem check-in prozess in einem hotel das man da wirklich humanitärer aktion braucht dachte mir so probierst du mal,
naja weil er natürlich so ein bisschen wie man das so erwartet dass user interface dieser applikationen die mir da entgegenspringen war so ein bisschen,
man muss na ja es lief augenscheinlich auf windows so das ist ja dann meistens schon.
Vorbei für dich.
Ja also rein ästhetisch hat es jetzt bei mir keine punkte abgeholt da kann man ja so einiges verkacken aber das war mir am ende gar nicht so wichtig dann habe ich meinen,
namen glaube ich eingegeben.
Und ich vermute mal das war's dann sogar schon also so security technisch,
ja gut also dass ich da jetzt grade gebucht habe das weiß man jetzt vielleicht nicht aber man kann sicherlich ein paar generischen namen mal ausprobieren und es könnte dann schon mal ganz interessant werden
weil das war dann sozusagen das einzige sicherheitsmerkmale was wirklich übertragen über überprüft wurde,
okay dann kam hier so buchung ja ja ja zimmer willst du haben alles klar aber und insofern ist vielleicht die sicherheitsfrage auch nicht ganz so problematisch,
ich muss ja dann auch gleich bezahlen so also sagt das teil ja hier karte bezahlen alles wunderbar.
Wieso gott dann pro jahr das mal hab natürlich irgendwie apple pay wollte ich natürlich dann gleich ausprobieren habe da meine uhr ran gehalten pipe,
und aus irgendwelchen gründen wollte er für meine karte noch eine pin haben was natürlich vollkommener humbug ist wenn man mit bezahlt braucht man keine pin eingegeben weil da dafür bezahlen wir mit apple pay,
ich bin schon autorisiert was willst du eigentlich ja gut so dann,
hat das dann halt nicht geklappt und was macht so eine applikation natürlich wenn man sagt zahlungs vorgang konnte nicht abgeschlossen werden alle daten werden gelöscht und das komplette system stellt sich wieder auf null und dann irgendwie alles vergessen was ich mühsam eingetippt habe,
das ist immer so okay alles klar zweiter versuch also kleiner tipp an leute die sowas programmieren macht das nicht,
zahlung vorgang kann auch mal schief gehen muss man jetzt kann man auch nochmal probieren so ist wirklich nicht so schlimm.
Sie haben zwei minuten zeit ihre daten einzugeben ansonsten wird automatisch alles resettet security feature.
Ja die einzige information die ich tatsächlich noch nachreichen musste war dann mein geburtsdatum weil das brauchen sie dann eben für diese meldung beim bei der stadt naja,
dann habe ich also alles nochmal eingegeben und so weiter und dann habe ich irgendwie andere karte mit apple probiert und er hatte irgendwie funktioniert das war's,
man kriegt so ein thermo print das ist dann gleichzeitig die rechnung und da steht dann drauf hier ist ihr sechsstelliger pin ihre zimmernummer ist,
danke an die richtige etage gehst diesem zimmer tipps zimmer nummer eins bis drin und das war dann mein schlüssel.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen unterwelt regt ich dachte dass du ab diesem moment einfach nur dein smartphone an so einer kontaktfläche hältst und das ist der schlüssel mit dem.
Die zimmertür sich öffnet das hätte ich jetzt so für so eine magic living the future gehalten.
Genau da können wir jetzt mal drüber reden also ich meine man muss immerhin anerkennen dass sie es mir erlaubt haben ohne irgendeine humane interaktion,
diese buchung wahrzunehmen zu bezahlen rechnung zu bekommen und zutritt und das zwar so und das sofort.
Das finde ich total super.
Ich fand es auch total so.
Überall weniger menschen.
Ja also wenn man so ein bisschen menschenscheu ist ist das hier nicht ganz hilfreich so damit läuft halt so ein hotelbetrieb mehr oder weniger auch,
naja also komplett support frei gibt ja dann immer mal wieder so sachen aber wenn es ansonsten alles okay ist kann man sich damit schon den einen oder anderen prozess sparen,
fand ich auf jeden fall interessant gibt es sicherlich woanders schon längst,
die uhr als schlüssel ja okay könnte man natürlich machen frage ist.
Code eigentlich praktischer,
also zum einen möchte ich ja nicht irgendwie mein mein mobiles endgerät auf irgendeine art und weise irgendwo registrieren,
ein code ist an andere weitergeben das heißt wenn mein meine begleitperson schon mal aufs zimmer will,
sagst du code und gut und es muss auch gar nicht so intuitiv das handy sein,
also das ist ja schon was sehr persönliches also ich möchte eigentlich dass er von irgendwie also nicht überall involviert haben,
aber das ist dann vielleicht auch einfach mein anspruch.
Ja ich finde auch sagen wir mal dieser vorgang war dann zumutbar du hast dann halt so ein so ein komisches keeper an der tür muss das kurz einschalten eintippen und machts klack klack und dann ist irgendwie offen also kenne ich türschließe systeme die weniger zuverlässig funktioniert.
Kleiner bad so ein kleiner thermo druck strahlt papierstreifen raus den muss ich irgendwie so abreißen oder die oder der ist schon portioniert den muss ich irgendwie in meine,
ja wo tue ich den überhaupt rein da ist eine eine sechsstellige zahl drauf ich werde bin nicht verrückt.
Machst du dir einfach ein handy foto von.
Ich bin doch nicht verrückt und merkt man jetzt noch eine andere pin-nummer zwischen den vielen die ich lebensnotwendige weise nicht vergessen darf also ich finde das eine zumutung.
Ich finde das praktische als so eine blöde karte.
Bei einem schlüssel ich finde ein schlüssel als überhaupt dass es seit jahren.
Aber dann musst du noch einen schlüssel nicht verlegen neben den anderen lebenswichtigen schlüssel die du ja sowieso die ganze zeit beide trägst.
Einen schlüssel hat immer so eine inhalt rente ich bin wertvoll ich schmeiß mich nicht weg vergiss mich nicht du mich lieber in den bundes ins bande schlüsselbund wollte ich sagen.
Das kannst du ja auch machen du hast diesen wisch.
Hallo,
ich zähle ja halt merk mir jetzt nicht die zacken am schlüssel sondern das ist dann einfach der schlüssel und da muss ich nicht mehr drüber nachdenken,
aber so und zwar immer wenn man da reingeht musst du diese sechs ziffern wieder tippen ne das ist für mich.
Da würde ich ja lieber immer temporär mit meinem fingerabdruck die war die war schon,
erst danach wieder löschen und hoffentlich nicht den triggert abdruck daten auch noch an die meldebehörde weiterleiten.
So sind die geschmäcker einfach.
Ja also also deine zukunft deine zukunft finde ich jetzt nicht so toll.
Ja ich habe ja nicht gesagt dass es die steigerungsfähig ist tatsächlich habe ich dann erst festgestellt und begriffen dass ich diesen ganzen check-in vorgang schon hätte vorher machen können.
Alles klingt doch.
So wie bei bahn komfort du drückst einfach auf seine app und wirst nicht mehr vom schaffner angequatscht.
Genau was ja übrigens auch funktioniert tatsächlich ja was du hast unwohlsein.
Nee ich bin einfach.
Ja aber das ist ja auch leben noch nicht gesehen.
Es ist jetzt ich habe vielleicht können wir da eine kleine runde draus machen jetzt erzähle ich euch mal mein wie hast du living.
Living the future.
Ok ich war vor anderthalb jahren auf habe ich eine radtour gemacht von heidelberg in die schweiz bis zum genfer see und das habe ich meistens mit dem rad gemacht und manchmal habe ich das rad auch geschoben,
oder manchmal auch das rad getragen auf den schultern wenn die berge zu steil war,
auf der rückfahrt hatte ich dann aber so die schnauze voll vom radfahren dass ich dann mit der bahn gefahren bin und zwar von www am genfer see,
mit der schweizer bahn bis nach bier und wie das so ist man kommt dann ja mit dem hauptbahnhof von so einer stadt raus und dann,
musste ich mich erstmal orientieren ich wollte also nicht die ganze zeit mit meinem fahrrad nebenher laufen sondern wollte das irgendwie anschließen und in der schweiz ist es ein bisschen anders als in berlin da kann man nicht einfach irgendwie ein fahrrad irgendwo anschließen da gibt's
richtig überall schilder und man sieht auch man wäre da sehr einsam mit so einem wilden
verhalten einfach zum fahrrad anzuschließen dann macht man sich schon richtig verdächtig in der schweiz die gehören alle andere richtig an den richtigen fleck.
Von wonach wo bist du nochmal gefahren.
Von von genfer see also jetzt nur die rückfahrt ne von genfer see der ist ein bisschen weiter weg da der große bananen familie von wem,
über wahrscheinlich losassen.
Von www.
Das ist neben neben.
Www.
Da ist nestlé das ist also ziemlich wohlhabender ort und ich glaube der davor der zug erst nach rosanen und von susanne eben danach biel,
und bier muss man immer slash nennen weil das quasi die einzige offizielle zweisprachigen stadt in der schweiz das ist da die hand jetzt ein bisschen.
Ich weiß schon.
Und es ist auch echt eine tolle stadt und,
ich glaube ich habe mich dann erstmal so orientiert dann wollte also das fahrrad abschließen und vor dem hauptbahnhof wenn man wenn du mal auf den hauptbahnhof ein schwenkst und dann auf dem vorplatz raus gehst siehst du wahrscheinlich dann einen riesigen parkplatz für fahrräder,
ah
Ja schön ich mache ja wieder.
Das ist der fahrrad sieht man's.
Ja ich mach google earth hier damit das visualisieren können aber eigentlich lautet die regel immer man redet gar nicht darüber dass ich das mache weil man fühlt sich die orange benachteiligt zurecht.
Ich war grade ich bin nicht so oft in der show und war jetzt so begeistert.
Okay also hast du ein fahrrad platz davor.
Und ich sage nur lustigen haufen digital schrott aus als hätte jemand eingeschmolzen die fahrräder und dann so als klumpen das ist irre,
das ist super interessant genau also was ich damit sagen ich komme also aus diesem säulen behandelnden porty raus orientiere mich blicke nach rechts blick nach links aha da ist das fahrrad,
parkplatz und schließt findet auch irgendwie noch um entsprechend ein einen platz und schließt das fahrrad an,
sieht aus wie er es einem total science-fiction albtraum diese diese digitalen artefakte sind ja absolut skandalös das ist es ist ja ein albtraum.
Ich kann das auch gerne mal mit apple maps zeigen da sieht's besser aus aber es kann sein dass es da nicht dreidimensionales.
Also es hat das ist wirklich das ist ja wie bei vier las vegas also als wollte gerade so trifft geschmissen,
das lustige ist ich will aber gar nicht über über bienen und bier sprechen sondern ich will quasi über das ist die gegenwart das heißt ich will mein fahrrad abschließen es gibt ein fahrrad platz platz,
und der ist so klar und evident dass man weiß was man tun muss,
jetzt aber zur zukunft ich bin da nämlich weiter gefahren mit der bahn nach basel und wenn wir jetzt mal nach basel auf dem bahnhofsvorplatz.
Basel.
Hingehen dann wirst du sehen was mein problem war dort ist nämlich kein verschmolzen der pixel haufen auf einmal.
Ich glaube in basel ist überhaupt gar kein platz oder ist das ein unterirdischer.
Nein nein da ist vor dem vor dem.
Was ist los kannst du nicht ertragen wenn ich hier auch mit.
Emotions das funktioniert für mich nicht gut wenn mein kopf gerade ist und sich nicht bewegt aber quasi alles in meinem sichtfeld das funktioniert nicht gut für mich.
Ja jetzt muss ich erstmal gucken was es hier welcher ist erzähl erstmal weiter.
Also ich komme da an dasselbe problem,
noch viel verschärfter weil basel ist wirklich eine kleine welt statt also das man merkt einfach sofort das ist so ein powerhouse,
da sieht man jetzt ach so ich darf das ja nicht sagen es gibt da so einen runden banken turm das ist die die bank für internationalen zahlungsausgleich und das ist gewissermaßen dort wo die finanzielle
erdachse geölt wird und wo ständig so gnome tags ein tag aus und finanzielle ja weltraum,
rotieren halten winkel nein ich meine.
Entschuldigung.
Achse genau ah das ist jetzt sehr gut jetzt sieht man glaube ich den bahnhofsvorplatz genau und auf jeden fall gibt's dort nichts außer das sind glaube ich diese diese stege das sind glaube ich straßenbahnhaltestellen,
und ich irre darum und jetzt rechts und links vom dach ausgesehen sieht man diese halbrunde teile und mit diesem blauen pool oder was das ist und da stand noch ein paar fahrräder dran,
und ausgerechnet an der stelle stand dann
man sieht so ein paar fahrräder sind da angelehnt schritt keine fahrräder anlegen da habe ich mich gedacht was kann denn das sein hier stehen noch lauter fahrräder und ausgerechnet in der schweiz wo es heißt und wo es wirklich streng ist tun die leute da ihr fahrrad hinstellen aber es sind so wenige warum das denn und ich
gucken mich und weiß nicht was mach ich es doch wie alle anderen stelle ich auch mein fahrrad da hin und,
aber irgendwie war mir unwohl weil wie kann das sein sind so wenige und in biel dass viel kleiner es waren so viele hunderte fahrräder an einem fleck und ich überleg und überleg und,
was ihr natürlich hier schon auf diesem bild seht sind die zwei.
Unter führung also diese rampen die in einem riesigen unterirdischen fahrrad,
tiefgarage führen die ich aber quasi in meiner blindheit überhaupt nicht erkannt habe dass es eine fahrrad tiefgarage gibt und das war halt dann insofern living the future weil.
Im zweiten anlauf dann mit meinem fahrrad darunter laufe und dann komme ich in so einem wirklich in so einer wunderwelt wo fünftausend fahrräder gefühlt in einer,
einen halle stehen und es gibt,
drei verschiedene stufen von was du mit deinem fahrrad machen kannst du kannst das fahrrad bewachten bereich geben du hast wenn du willst kannst du auch.
Fahrradboxen nur für dein fahrrad mieten die sind dann quasi abschließbar das ist die deluxe variante und es gibt einen unbewachten teil,
wo du dein fahrrad einfach irgendwie abstellen kannst wo aber dann keine garantie gegeben wird dass es dann hinterher noch da ist und ich glaube ich habe dann die mittlere variante gewählt und dann,
und das war die also dieses ganze konzept ist so living die future dass ich überhaupt von der idee so eines fahrrad paar krauses dass es außerhalb meiner vorstellungswelt war kam mir da kam ich mich auf einmal so so,
ja so zu rückwärtsgewandt vor dass ich konnte mir das ja gar nicht vorstellen sonst hätte ich das ja sofort gefunden und gesehen ich war da komplett überrascht und,
und dann stehe ich halt wirklich wie der ochs vorm berg weil das ist ein bisschen wie,
wenn man das fahrrad an diesen diesen kontrollierten bereich reinschieben will dann ist das wie so als scanner prozess und dann,
versuche ich das fahrrad so reinzuschieben und nichts passiert kein lichtlein blinkt und irgendwann hinter mir stehen so drei vier genervte,
basel menschen schon und irgendeiner muss das fahrrad schon nicht schrank geschrieben.
Mir das fahrrad entrissen voller wut wolle dieser metropolitano,
die man hier in berlin ja auch kennt wenn die touristen direkt hinter der hinter der rolltreppe erstmal so nach dem stadtplan suchen ne und hat dann also für mich dieses fahrrad dann,
und dann habe ich das natürlich nochmal entsprechend auch nochmal gesichert in ein diese wahnsinnige,
ja da ist er jetzt sieht man auch ein schönes bild von diesem fahrrad unterirdischen fahrradmessen,
und da habe ich mich zuerst mal gefühlt als wie so ein mensch aus der aus der dritten welt der zum ersten mal in so ein entwickeltes land gegangen ist und so sachen wie eine rolltreppe,
ampel oder vielleicht auch rolltreppe und dann fällt er einfach hin weil er,
weil er nicht weiß dass er dann wieder laufen muss das war so peinlich und aber gleichzeitig auch so ein living future schön war halt zu sehen auch in einem so fortgeschrittenen land wie der schweiz ist halt die zukunft noch ungleich verteilt in biene
war es halt noch so wie man es kennt aus deutschland aber basel lebt halt schon in der zukunft.
Ich finde das sehr lustig dass die zukunft dann entscheidend street spricht.
Deutschland.
Also ich meine die schweiz ist natürlich auch teilweise immer mit mit mit mit einem bein sind sie auch immer sehr in der vergangenheit aber mit dem anderen auch also sie überspannen die gegenwart auf eine beeindruckende art und weise.
Ich hab fernweh nach urlaub.
Durch das was wir jetzt erzählen.
Durch die schweiz.
Ach so durch die schweiz tja was können wir dagegen tun aufbrechen in ferne weiter ich wollte mal kurz du hast,
vor der sendung gregor mich ne du hast ja auch hier war das manchmal weiß man nicht mal was man vorher deswegen sollte man vor podcast nie reden weil.
Du hast doch angefangen.
Ja aber dann weiß man immer nicht was ja.
Ich werde dich nächstes mal daran erinnern dass wir vorher nicht reden dürfen ist für mich total okay.
Ja oder man sollte vielleicht einfach das essen in so in so eine preshow-match einfach integrieren dann dann ist man halt schon dabei und dann hört man vielleicht ein paar schmatzer aber dann ist man.
Schmatzer hassen die leute.
Okay okay.
Zurecht zurecht,
nein aber du du sagtest ja dass dass du die die die den kontakt zum podcasting so ein bisschen verloren hast das war aber schon in der sonne sendung was immer so ganz genau aber deine frage war was so metaebene,
was genau was macht eigentlich die metaebene so genau und ich wollte jetzt hier auch nochmal die gelegenheit nutzen das vielleicht mal kurz zu erklären beziehungsweise,
auf so einen anderen aspekt dabei noch mit zu kommen nämlich,
erstmal ich habe im letzten jahr so ein move gemacht und raum zeit so ein bisschen,
anders aufgestellt,
dadurch dass die spenden situation sich so etwas verbessert hatte dachte ich mir so okay alles klar jetzt kannst du auch mal ein bisschen steiler gehen und lagere jetzt tätigkeiten aus,
konkret redaktionelle art was für mich extrem befreiend ist weil ich einfach merke,
es ist immer gut dass ich so ein bisschen auf seine stärken zu konzentrieren und meine stärke ist in dem fall halt einfach die das machen das konkrete produzieren durchführen moderieren.
Veröffentlichen von sendung so ganz plane reihe hat mich teilweise enorm aufgehalten also klar terminplanung terminfindungen und zwar das mache ich natürlich immer noch alles selber muss ja auch selber machen das macht mir auch spaß,
weil das immer auf schöne schöne wege an schöne orte auch führen kann auf jeden fall hat sich das
bei raum zeit im podcast über raumfahrt und andere kosmische angelegenheiten ich das mittlerweile nenne
sehr positiv ausgewirkt was leute die dem kanal folgen auch gemerkt haben dürfen nachdem ich nämlich so eine weile gestreichelt bin und sogar ein zeitraum von einem jahr,
etwas unter produktive kaskade an sendungen rausgebracht habe sich das jetzt ganz anders aus,
tatsächlich habe ich also im letzten jahr den monatsabständen gehalten und durch verschiedene verbesserungen noch bin ich jetzt
drauf und dran raum zeit wieder in seinen alten ursprünglichen veröffentlichung plus zurückzuführen nämlich alle drei wochen,
als yes von dem ich viel halte was gibt's noch lachen.
Es ist sehr lustig als wir die beiden je produziert drei wochen ist dann der lächerlich ich versuche alle drei wochen zum friseur zu zu zu kommen,
alle drei wochen wäre das ideal
für dass man gepflegten haarschnitt hat aber drei wochen kriege ich nie gebacken weil vierzehn täglich ja wöchentlich okay täglich auch vierwöchentliche frisst fast wie monatlich aber drei wochen,
wie kriegt man drei wochen in irgendeinem vernünftigen lebenszyklus hinein und dann kommst du und sagst eigentlich ist das,
idealer zeit niemand macht was mit drei wochen außer eben dem vorschlag also drei wochen zum friseur zu gehen der einzige,
kontinuität oder frequenz die ich in dem bereich und du bist jetzt der zweite mensch der das auch noch aktiv wirklich durchführt.
Was war denn der erste.
Das sind die friseure aber die machen es ja nur als vorschlag weil keiner geht alle drei wochen zum friseur.
Ich ich bin schon seit oh gott ich glaub ich war seit zwanzig jahren nicht mehr beim friseur.
Kann ich von mir jetzt nicht behaupten aber mir ist bestimmt auch schon ich gehe glaube ich alle zwei jahre.
Irgendwie so immer wenn es mein wenn die haare nerven wenn den haare nerven kommst du einfach.
Genauso ist bei mir auch aber ich mache mir die selber ab.
Wir waren jetzt hier bei abständen das ist jetzt diese friseurs geschichte auf und es ist einfach das einzige mir bekannte abstand frequenz format oder modus den ich kenne,
der mir schon mal empfohlen worden ist und den ich auch für richtig halte den man aber nicht durchführen kann weil drei wochen ist nicht im menschlichen rhythmus.
So ein digitaler kalender hilft bei sowas der einen regelmäßig erinnert in.
Moment moment warum also warum.
Warum ist jetzt aber okay was ist was was wie hast du eigentlich gesagt das wäre ziemlich idealer abstand oder sowas.
Genau ist es genau ja okay.
Und dann muss ich halt lachen mal für mich ist es das das undenkbar erste.
Ja gut aber du bist ja auch an der receiving and,
so und da ist es beim podcast meistens ohnehin relativ egal weil du hörst dann wenn du zeit hast und mal hast du viel zeit und man hat wenig zeit und dann dann ist sozusagen der rhythmus indem etwas veröffentlicht wird eigentlich nur wichtig damit,
dann auch deine entsprechend gefüllt ist wenn du denn da mal dazu kommst so als produzent wiederum,
habe ich jetzt eigentlich alles,
mal gehabt so also ich habe wochenrückblick aus mit logbuch netzpolitik ich habe zwei wochen mit der frische euch habe und alle zwei wochen ich habe drei wochen mit raum zeit gehabt,
vier wochen mit raum zeit gehabt und mit anderen sachen auch und auch weniger so und,
bei der bestimmung was jetzt das richtige zeitfenster ist,
muss man verschiedene sachen mit berücksichtigen das eine ist natürlich erstmal okay wie will ich als podcast überhaupt wahrgenommen werden.
Wie sehr sollen sich leute noch an einen erinnern ich bin mal wieder eine neue folge rauskommt wenn du wöchentlich raus drückst,
dann darf es auch nicht mehr so lang sein,
kannst du jetzt nicht jede woche irgendwie drei stunden klopper raushauen klar einzelne ausnahmen und so weiter aber das ist irgendwie schwierig gegenteil bestätigen die regel,
das funktioniert mit logbuch netzpolitik irgendwie ganz kurz zur stunde anderthalb hinaus aber ich will mich jetzt gar nicht so sehr auf diese länge festlegen sondern das hat er so ein bisschen was damit zu tun wie oft.
Erinnerst du die leute sozusagen da dran dass es dich noch gibt,
und wenn du das halt so alle jubeljahre machst wie das natürlich jetzt gerade etwas suboptimal da versuche ich auch gerade wege zu finden das zu ändern komme ich vielleicht nochmal zu aber.
Bei raum zeit bin ich ursprünglich mal mit drei wochen gestartet weil ich mir einfach dachte,
es muss halt auch noch zu produzieren sein brauchst vorlauf du musst irgendwie auch genug themen haben muss dann irgendwie auch redaktionell musste einfach genug hinterherkommen dass dass dass er einfach auch leute hast und oft ist es auch grade bei
leuten im wissenschaftlichen bereich oder alle leute die eigentlich so ein bisschen gefragter sind
wir haben jetzt auch nicht so ohne weiteres immer einen termin im angebot der passt schon gar nicht so eine termine wie ich sie haben will mit dir nimm dir mal mehrere stunden zeit und dann quatschen wir mal,
und dementsprechend,
war dann so drei wochen mein vorschlag ist ja eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert weil nach drei wochen erinnerst du dich immer noch sehr gut an etwas,
nach vier wochen nimmt es schon langsam weg alles was du über einen monat hinaus geht,
findet gefühlt irgendwann gar nicht mehr so richtig statt dann einfach zu lange her,
zwei wochen ist eigentlich sehr gut um so eine regelmäßige druckbetankung,
zu liefern so und eine woche ist dann schon hardcore und wochen-programme sind eben auch schwer durchzuhalten allein schon weil sie einem selbst pro woche halt den ganzen tag mindestens
rausnehmen,
und es ist schwierig also ich könnte jetzt zum beispiel noch so ein wochen vom markt kann ich nicht machen aber ich könnte natürlich alle sachen die mit drei bis vier wochen sind passt schon nochmal was.
Der kann halt schon durch diesen drei wochen rhythmus hast du dann eben auch mal eine woche wo quasi dein wöchentliches dein zwei wöchentliches dein vier wöchentliches
produktion kommt dann noch als fünfte
deine drei wöchentliche reingefetzt das heißt es ist dann auch schwer zu kontrollieren hinsichtlich dass dann mal der ziemlich wohl aus temperierter arbeitsprozess quasi dann durch so eine so eine so eine arbeit spitze erfährt.
Ja gut aber die veröffentlichung ist ja nicht identisch mit wandels produziert und aufnimmst es hat dann eher du musst halt nur so mir wie viele sendungen muss ich denn eigentlich insgesamt machen um den und den.
Okay in weiterer arbeitsteiligen komplikationen kontexten ist es ziemlich klar dass es das drei wöchentliche format eben überhaupt nicht gibt weil es gibt keine drei wöchentliche erscheinenden magazine im herkömmlichen.
Feigheit ist das.
Nein ich glaube einfach dass es überhaupt nicht fassbar ist weil du kannst monatshälfte wochen heft und dann machst du was dazwischen das ist das zwei wöchentliche,
aber dieses drei wöchentliche ding das ist so jenseits das ist das ist halt das raum zeitfenster dass du da für dich.
Sehr schön gesagt das raum zeitfenster.
Ich finde es tatsächlich ganz spannend weil ich also bei agiler softwareentwicklung hat man ja immer im prinzip so seine seine sprints und die kann man rein theoretisch beliebig lang festlegen
sollte halt nicht irgendwie länger als einunddreißig tage sein weil dann würden werden die sprints zu groß und sollen nicht kürzer als eine woche sein weil dann kriegt man nicht so richtig viel gewuppt
und da ist tatsächlich so zwei bis drei wochen so ein klassischer zyklus aber das ist halt komplett.
Kalender eigentlich unabhängig weil du hast dann einfach deinen tonus von immer zwei beziehungsweise immer drei wochen und ich finde tatsächlich wir haben jetzt lange oder standard den so kenne sind halt immer zwei wochen,
ich würde aber gerne mal ausprobieren so eine zwei plus
eins kombination weil man dann wirklich zwei wochen coden kann und eine woche hat man dann für vor und nachbearbeitet und gerade wenn man
zum beispiel medizinprodukt hat wo viel dokumentiert viel gewartet werden muss viel auch irgendwie geplant im kleinen team finde ich das halt tatsächlich eine
relativ praktikable lösung,
weil dann hat man halt zwei wochen regel programm und eine woche für so andere dinge die halt mit auch anfallen und das kann ich mir tatsächlich wiederum extrem gut vorstellen gerade für so einen podcast weil dann hat man,
zwei wochen irgendwie keine ahnung so ein zeitfenster wo man,
standarddinge macht und man hat ja trotzdem seinen regelmäßigen tonus an dem man zum beispiel daran arbeiten könnte wenn man so arbeitet und eine woche wo dann halt,
releast wird.
Ja also.
Im weitesten sinne.
Im idealfall läuft's natürlich nicht so also ich mache jetzt zum beispiel gerade die planung für dieses fürs erste dreiviertel jahr tatsächlich also ich habe jetzt quasi.
Den gibt es ein zweites dreiviertel jahr.
Das folgt aus der konsequenten anwendung des drei wochen rhythmus verteilt sich das jahr zwei dreiviertel jahre auf.
Total in ordnung für mich.
Ja was wollte ich jetzt gerade nachreichen.
Du machst gerade die dreiviertel jahres.
Ah ja genau ich mache mache also ich plane das erste dreiviertel jahr weil ich weiß dass ich im sommer,
eigentlich nichts produzieren will oder zumindest nicht mehr so viel,
produzieren will einfach um eine relativ ausgedehnte urlaubsphase realisieren zu können beziehungsweise es ohnehin das problem ist dass mit den sendungen die so vorweg mache im sommer,
in der regel keine termine zu finden sind also wenn ich jetzt wissenschaftler und so weiter die sind halt dann auch alle irgendwann im urlaub und das zieht sich ebenso von juli bis,
ende
august teilweise in den september noch mit rein und ich habe halt so ein so ein zwei monate zweieinhalb monate block der
immer schwierig war da mein ziel jetzt ist konsequent raum zeit und zunehmenden maße auch die anderen sachen mehr auf so einen rhythmus zu bekommen,
und dann ein entsprechendes pensum zu erfüllen muss ich einfach mehr vorproduzieren,
deswegen tue ich das jetzt gerade und bin schon ganz gut also ich glaube ich habe so alle themen bis zu mai oder so stehen im prinzip schon,
auf der liste und dann produziere ich halt auch eher so okay alles klar was habe ich jetzt noch anrufen termine wann könnte es passen und ich nehme dann eigentlich immer den ersten.
Besten termin so weil was weg ist ist weg hat auch den vorteil,
teilweise also ich hatte sogar schon mal als ich in barcelona war habe ich das sogar so gemacht dass ich meine ganzen terminplanung mit google ausgemacht habe also ich habe ernsthaft all die orte wo ich hinfahren muss,
fähnchen reingesetzt weil ich ja immer ich war ja mal weit weg und zwar dann immer so wenn ich dann
mal nach deutschland fliege dann will ich halt auch möglichst viele mitkriegen und habe mir das also wirklich so geometrie optimiert mit von wo fahre ich nach wo kriege ich die termine irgendwie zusammen hat nicht unbedingt immer funktioniert aber oft funktioniert auch ganz gut
ja dann war ich,
dann entsprechend unterwegs weil er auch irgendwo in einem bei einem termin mich dann auch aufgetaucht und habe festgestellt ich habe mich um drei monate vertan na ja so viel dazu.
Ja traumzeit findet statt und ich will auch an dieser stelle noch mal drauf hinweisen dass ich da gerade eine ganz interessante folge rausgehauen habe sogar du hast es bemerkt.
Weil du es gibt twittert hast.
Weiß getwittert habe.
Das ist ja nicht mehr so deine dein dein revier so richtig ja.
Wieso weil ich da nicht.
Du bist der fast der vor jahren den exodos ins app dort net angetreten als deine ganze gefolgschaft damit mitgenommen twitter gelehrt und den trollen überlassen.
Hatte wenig folgen glaube ich.
Naja und dann bist du aber nie wieder richtig zurückgekommen war so mein eindruck.
Das stimmt gar nicht ich habe eigentlich twitter nie verlassen.
Ok und.
Ich filme ich fühl mich bloß nicht so herausgefordert zu allem scheiß was zu schreiben also muss sagen dass mich.
Du hast ja auch genug podcast dafür.
Ja aber.
Weil zu allem was zu sagen hat muss natürlich nicht mehr zu allem was treten.
Ja aber ich meine wenn man auf twitter was du sagst dann ist es halt meistens blöde empört scheiße also es.
Ja das ist ja jetzt.
Das hat so viele leute befallen dieses virus.
Das klingt aber jetzt hier wie talkshow drei nach neun und alter weiser mann beschwert sich über diese soziale das kenne ich aus dem fernsehen.
Über meine anderen war.
Geh doch hier nicht in den metaebene und mir dann so drei nach neun oder markus lanz sprüche abzuholen das kann ich doch zuhause vorm fernseher haben.
Versteht mich nicht falsch es ist eine reine beobachtung dass dass da einfach viel vor sich hin empört wird und ich,
mich mich erreicht das nicht mehr.
Twitter ja das wäre.
Ach ja das ist ja nicht die die krankheit heißt nicht twitter.
Schon klar es wird auch nie wieder sein wie früher der zauber des anfangs ist vorbei aber.
Damit gar nicht sagen.
Ich finde es soziale netzwerke sind noch nicht tot.
Soweit wollte ich auch nicht gehen ich habe nur gesagt ich nehme daran teil und ich benutze twitter auch seit anfang an vor allem als verkündigung,
organ das ist halt für meine publikationen form sehr angemessen ja podcast ist darauf hinweisen et cetera ich weiß nicht könnt ihr das auch auf facebook machen ma ja aber nicht weil,
genau und ja und auch instagram und was weiß ich aber.
Mit der ebene instagram-account es wäre lustig.
Das wäre total super also einfach so ein foto von wie das hier so aussieht ganz groß.
Ja und und und die sonnenuntergang und dann logan sprüche drauf nein.
Nein nein.
Nein du musst das nicht aber ich stimme dir ich stimme dir im prinzip zu.
Ich bin nicht so der ich muss nicht die ganze zeit meine privatsphäre nach außen kehren also das sorry aber den den move mach ich irgendwie nicht mit das ist einfach das da bin ich das nicht meine generation.
Ich muss sagen für mich ist twitter auch primär ich nutze ich nutze die plattform sehr gerne aber primär um zu konsumieren um um,
leute versuchen besser verstehen zu lernen mit denen ich sonst halt nichts zu tun hätte,
aber ich schreibe jetzt auch nicht so viel sinnvolle sachen.
Über die normalen leute auf twitter nichts von sich geben dann hast du ja nur die freaks die quasi ihren kram da raus hauen und schreien und dann ist das ja per se kommt das ja in so einem.
Das würde jetzt irgendwie negativ rüberkommen wenn
freaks was negatives werden aber ich finde es ja gerade gut wenn halt leute von denen man sonst nicht so viel hört mal ein bisschen mehr oder zumindest die möglichkeit hat von denen etwas mitzukommen.
Also ich finde von tim würde ich schon gerne mehr hören was er so erzählt weil ich wie gesagt irgendwie seit einiger zeit die freakshow nicht mehr höre,
bestimmt tolle sachen zum beispiel zu diesem future moment,
mit einem foto von diesem komischen check-in-automaten das finde ich toll.
Ja das hätten andere leute gemacht.
Und du machst es halt nicht.
Ich mache das lieber im podcast.
Und das finde ich ein bisschen schade weil so ein paar punktuelle perlen,
vielleicht würde es so abstinent menschen wie mich dann vielleicht auch wieder eher dazu bringen wieder reinzuholen für mich.
Aber das schöne ist es muss ja auch einfach nicht sein es muss ja nicht eine person sein die alle bedürfnisse erfüllt es geht ja auch gar nicht.
Ach doch also das könnte ich eigentlich schon.
Du möchtest alle bedürfnisse von jedem einzelnen.
Möchte gerne die eine person sein die alle bedürfnisse erfüllt okay.
Dann musst du mir twittern.
Ja also also ich finde es schon komisch also die habe ich eher kontakt über ganz ganz normale wie früher so eine sms oder so als über über so wie man das heute so tut also.
Man macht das heute nicht richtig keine sms schickt mir auch schon so messages im sinne von messenger.
Das finde ich schon ganz lustig weil die kommt bei mir an und sehen aus wie sms und dann sitzt aber nochmal gespiegelt auf dem rechner,
da habe ich sie nicht erst auf dem rechner gesehen und dann habe ich vielleicht so wie auf dem handy nicht mitbekomme ich will damit sagen,
du begleitest meinem sozialen umfeld weil du dich so machst auf twitter ich prangere das an.
Okay gut.
Notifications für tim einfach anschalten dann wirst du jedes mal kriegst du eine kurze zusammenfassung wenn er wieder was von sich gegeben hat.
Ich werde jetzt auf jeden fall nicht.
Soviel sein.
Ich werde auf jeden fall nicht in so eine digitale diary aus.
Es sollte schon mit maß und mitte ja so und ich weißt du wer wer so viel,
öffentlich erzählt wie du ich glaube,
man kann quasi deinen kompletten wortschatz aus anhand natürlich deiner ganzen bisherigen beiträge quasi bis auf bis auf wenige hundert worte wahrscheinlich ermitteln können und so ein tim bot wahrscheinlich programmieren der so spät,
wie du und du hast so viel über die jahre entblößt kann eigentlich so ein ganz normales harmloses,
soziales netzwerk gar nicht mit beisteuern.
Ja
Überleg mal welche ich lieber chat hallo,
wenn ihr dem tim regelmäßig zuhört überlegt mal welche andere person aus einem sozialen umfeld hört ihr alle vierzehn tage fünf stunden lang zu in so einem gesprächssituationen.
Vier stunden vierzehn.
Ich nehme jetzt nochmal alle,
und nochmal alle an wenn wir die richtige metaebene ultras seid dann hört ihr vielleicht mehrere von von von tims produktion dann habt ihr so eine netto,
tim spricht zeit da bin ich sicher es gibt keine andere person in eurem näheren und nächsten sozialen umfeld außer vielleicht eure stimme in eurem eigenen kopf die so viel spricht wie der tim.
Und du möchtest jetzt das team noch mehr auf noch viel anderen medien sich zur verfügung stellt damit man noch mehr tim konsumieren kann.
Da bin ich mehr tim in in kürzerer zeit weil ich will halt nicht diese fünfzehn wochenstunden opfern was auch in fünfzehn tweets gesagt werden könnte.
Ich könnte bell extra ein podcast für dich aufsetzen der alle drei wochen fünf minuten lang nur sagt geht zum friseur.
Kannst du auch noch was was macht ihr mal so einen metaebene der rest.
Das sind doch die previews nee du musst einfach nur noch die previews lies hören das ist quasi das komplette zusammenfassung der vier stunden.
Genau ich will ich will für die meter podcast show über übergreifend das wäre gut ja,
nein das war ja nur der anspruch weil der tim sagt ja mein privatleben darüber spreche ich nicht tim du sprichst über ganz viel und persönliches und privates in deinen shows.
Persönlich ist schon privates eigentlich nicht.
Ja das hängt immer ein bisschen davon ab was es privat was es persönlich ich finde dass du sprichst über dinge die werden wir wirklich viel zu privat.
Ok podcast zum beispiel ach ja.
Wenn ihr sowas wie die wahl ja das beispiel das finde ich ziemlich.
Es gibt noch einen grund warum ich mehr raum zeit mache und ich wollte jetzt an dieser stelle habe ich das in der liste meiner friedhof schon gemacht oder es ist jetzt ein doppel plus.
Wir sind hier in der freakshow.
Ja ne ich hatte das im logbuch gemacht oder hatte ich das letzte mal auch schon fast schon darauf hingewiesen auf die.
Da ich gerade nicht weiß worauf du hinweisen.
Letzte folge.
Nee da war die noch gar nicht raus.
Ich glaube die war da noch gar nicht raus genau die war da noch gar nicht raus also mache ich das jetzt einfach mal und zwar hatte ich eine sendung über space-x gemacht habe ich eine sendung über space-x gemacht,
und die ist ganz gut geworden und deswegen wollte ich da auch noch mal drauf hinweisen weil wenn man schon mal was gutes macht sollte man darauf hinweisen.
Weil ich auch in einem tweet davon gelesen habe,
ich dachte das wäre jetzt schon eine ältere folge von raum zeit was weiß ich von vor fünf jahren und die wäre jetzt durch die aktuellen erfolge von,
spacex was weiß ich glaube das war jetzt der letzte große stand war ja dieses abkoppeln rettungsmannschaft vor noch in diesem schon in diesem jahr war das und das,
quasi durch diese aktualität die spacex dadurch gewonnen hätte das dann nochmal leute auf einen älteren podcast von dir aufmerksam geworden ist der quasi von der long quasi wieder so in die charts zurück gespült worden ist das ist aber was ganz aktuelles.
Richtig es ist die aktuelle folge die erste die du siehst wenn du jetzt auf die
homepage gehst und dir habe ich zwar bereits im november aufgenommen aber da ich mich als also einen engeren rhythmus halte war die eben dann eben für den siebzehnten januar geplant da kam sie dann eben auch raus.
Da war der entweder ganz schön viel viel leitend das muss ich ja schon mal sagen.
Warum was schrubbe ich denn.
Was auch noch eben da auf deinem twitter profil du schreibst ja nicht viel das können wir doch sofort sehen.
Stimmt,
ja was soll ich denn geschrieben wie sowas mal wüsste.
So viel zeug hast du getwittert.
Na ich rede biete doch das eine oder andere hier.
Fällt mir überhaupt nicht genau da.
Ja ich sage einfach nur dass er durch die decke geht und.
Geht gerade in der download durch die decke ja okay also für dich war es halt klar für mich war es aber der podcast spacex der hätte eben auch schon vor fünf jahren hätte stattfinden ersetzt basics durch was weiß ich.
Okay ich werde demnächst nochmal versuchen etwas genauer darauf hinzuweisen aber du kannst auch einfach den raum zeit twitter-account folgen und da weißt du das immer alles aktuell.
Ja das.
Also wenn ich da auf was altes hinweise dann schreibe ich das auch.
Okay.
Und was können wir hier kurz drüber sprechen sind da gibt's sowas wie eine gibt's da so einen shake sowas wo wir sagen kannst.
Ja also ich glaube was ganz ganz gut geworden ist in der folge ist dass also ich habe mit hans königsbrunn gesprochen der ist der vierte mitarbeiter von basics gewesen also der war wirklich von anfang an mit dabei,
deutscher und ja der hat da eben diese ganze raketen entwicklung mit vorangetrieben und ist jetzt mittlerweile der chef der mission wahrheit also der überblickt im prinzip alle missionen,
äußerst gesprächiger mensch und mir ging's ja vor allem darum so ein bisschen herauszuarbeiten so okay was was ist jetzt eigentlich so the secret source was was macht ihr eigentlich anders,
dass ihr es schafft innerhalb von zehn jahren von wir haben noch nicht mal eine rakete zu wir haben mehr staats als alle anderen.
Wir machen es wie die nasa.
Wie da so.
Die wurde neunzehnhundertneunundfünfzig gegründet neunundsechzig auf dem mond geflogen ja so.
Gut gut point er wollte eigentlich auf dem mars vielleicht kommt er da auch noch hin,
aber die nase hatte dann definitiv erstmal mehr geld als startkapital glaube ich als spacex,
nichtsddestotrotz hat's geklappt und das war mir eben so wichtig mal rauszuarbeiten okay was was ist denn eigentlich so die,
die motivation oder was was ist eure methode wie wie was habt ihr für eine interne kommunikation wie wie wie sprecht ihr miteinander wie organisiert ihr wie geht ihr mit fehlern um was habt ihr für eine fehler
kultur wie wie verfolgt ihr neue ansätze etcetera das ist ja immer das das das das große problem
dass ich eigentlich unternehmen die auch so halbwegs oder organisationen im allgemeinen
wenn die erstmal irgendwo halbwegs etabliert sind und nicht alles frisch ist dann wird's natürlich schwierig und du musst dann irgendwie aufrechterhalten und diesen ps aufrecht erhalten ob das basics dann,
in der zukunft noch so gelingen wird das wird man sehen aber dass ich natürlich jetzt auch viel mit dieser person elon masken natürlich auch verbindet der ja nicht nur in diesem unternehmen gezeigt hat
diese herangehensweise ist ja mittlerweile schon sein dritter großer wurf.
Also ich habe dazu eine,
ich habe dazu eine theorie oder im begriff der ist aber ein ganz anderen zusammenhang nämlich mit den mit den hacker spaces gekommen weil es gibt vor etwa zehn jahren gab es ja so eine gründungswelle von
hacker spaces makers spacers und jetzt ist so quasi,
so die erste begeisterung pionierphase so am abgeben und letztes jahr gab es wirklich beim kongress relativ viele so,
inoffizielle talks auf diesen diesen,
bühne bühne wo halt so durch sagt er wie geht's weiter so eine art fetik oder und,
da ist mir aufgefallen weil die habe ich nicht
ich habe mir das angehört und bin dann irgendwann so eingegriffen weil ich das so spannend fand hab dann gesagt ja hier ich gehöre zur see base und wir sind schon seit über zwanzig jahren in dem bereich tätig und es gibt diesen,
diesen raum diesen verein ja immer noch und dann ist mir in dem moment klar geworden warum es das,
und dann habe ich gesagt das ist institutionelle überforderung.
Ständig also um diesen ganzen laden laden am laufen zu halten muss man wie beim fahrrad man kann nicht rollen sondern muss immer wieder treten sonst fällt man einfach um und ich glaube viele dieser hacks spaces die sind zu klein,
als sodass es finanziell relativ schnell abgesichert ist sie base war nie,
abgesichert finanziell du musst dir immer etwas tun immer neue leute ranziehen immer irgendwie sich interessant machen dass da leute kommen und sei es nur dass sie irgendwie über das bar geschäft so diese laufenden fehl also vielleicht vierzig
maximal sechzig prozent kam über die mitgliedsbeiträge es war immer ein riesiger fehlbau,
weil es ging um viele viele tausend euro pro monat die mussten irgendwie reingebracht werden und das hat den laden immer irgendwie so agil gehalten und ich glaube das was dabei elon musk passiert ist auch mit diesem nun schaut projekts mit diesem ständig sich
so unerreichbar also erstmal so unglaubliche ziele zu setzen hält man gewissermaßen diesen pioniergeist am laufen und es gibt ja auch immer wieder so eine,
eine gewisse pionier
truppe unter leuten also leute die gerne was zum ersten mal machen die so richtig anpacken und es gibt dann so eine zweite oder dritte generation von leuten die schon den etablierten strukturen was cooles machen wollen aber ganz anders ticken.
Ich glaube es gibt immer wieder auch pionier typen die du in solche unternehmen auch wieder reinziehen kannst das heißt selbst wenn jemand,
irgendwie über zehn fünfzehn jahre,
punkt erreicht hat wo er vielleicht nicht mehr in dieser pionier tätigkeit ist sondern daneben wächst natürlich dann auch so dass es wahrscheinlich auch strukturen hat aber dann kannst du es auch verlassen und oder machst eine bestimmte position frei wo jeder
jemand wieder kommt und sagt das hat noch niemand gemacht und deswegen interessiert mich das überhaupt es zu versuchen und das konnte ich mir vorstellen dass das so ein bisschen der das ist,
was anderes ist weil's bei allen anderen institutionen die diesen so einen starken erstmal selbst,
erhaltungstraining nur noch nur noch haben,
ja so ganz egal ob du nasa bist oder die bundesagentur für arbeit,
was was quasi durch deinen bürokratisches black box so fließt ist eigentlich egal hauptsache das fließt gleichgewicht es gewahrt.
Ja also.
Hat er das auch so gesagt.
Nicht mit den worten aber,
ich war auch mehr mehr so eine feststellung ich will jetzt auch nicht zu viel spoilern können sicher alle irgendwie nochmal selber anhören dich eingeschlossen,
zweiter schöner teil weil dann dass ich mit ihm so einen falken nein flug,
schritt für schritt durchmarschieren konnte also wirklich so vom vom start weg natürlich mit fokus auf dieser landung,
also was eigentlich weil weil das war sozusagen das das neue also es ist herum,
raketen technik im allgemeinen zu erklären sondern konkret dieses was macht ihr da eigentlich,
wie seid ihr darauf gekommen das so zu machen was habt ihr alles ausprobiert was nicht funktioniert hat und warum hat dann funktioniert,
also ich bin mit dem ergebnis eigentlich ganz zufrieden und da ich auch schon weiß was so die nächsten themen sein werden kann ich euch nur empfehlen runter zu abonnieren ist toll.
Cliffhänger,
schön geteasert.
Boah ist genau,
und das ganze hat dann irgendwie auch dazu geführt bei mir also mir geht's eigentlich schon ein bisschen länger so,
aber es hat mich komischerweise vor einem jahr selber nochmal gegriffen als ich bin nämlich mit traumzeit angefangen hatte ist ja auch kein geheimnis hatte ich ja eigentlich von raumfahrt keine ahnung,
also gar keine ahnung.
Und jetzt nochmal astronaut werden.
Nee nee nee nee das nicht nö aber in meiner seite man macht das jetzt raum zeit seit zweitausend,
ja
Expert.
Ja ich glaube ja ne also bin ich nicht so also gar nicht auch nicht nur im ansatz.
Aber du kennst diese experts sketch oder von collegium.
Kann sein dass ich nicht so mal raus tatsache ist,
konnte ich halt am anfang noch also ich weiß nicht vielleicht hätte es hinbekommen aber ich war mir nicht sicher und das hat ja schon mal was aus ob ich die planeten unseres sonnensystems in der richtigen reihenfolge hätte aufzählen können.
Kennst du wahrscheinlich auch noch einen zu viel aufgezählt.
Das wahrscheinlich nicht aber ich hätte mit der reihenfolge werde ich mir nicht so sicher gewesen,
und überhaupt so dieses ja man weiß ja immer so sachen aber weiß man sie eigentlich wirklich und kann man sich dann irgendwie auch erklären dass ja dann immer so das ding und da hier mal so ein so ein so ein so ein so ein,
erklärer bin also ich erkläre auch gern leuten in einer bar irgendwas also,
ich erkläre sowieso generell immer gerne was also und zwar einfach nur aus dem spaß des erklärens heraus ich weiß nicht bock irgendwie total ich mag.
Ist es eher du magst es geschichten zu erzählen oder du magst es wissen zu verbreiten oder beides.
Ja im idealfall tut man ja beides auch
gleichzeitig also man muss man muss eine gute geschichte erzählen um wissen vermitteln zu können du kannst dich einfach nur so manuel runterlesen so so und so das langweilig muss es halt schon auch
machen und rund machen und gute erklärung liefern und aber umso besser du es erklären möchtest umso besser muss es auch selber verstehen und ich merke einfach wie mir einfach
viel fehlte so durch diese zahlreichen podcast ich nun gemacht habe von dem ich auch die hälfte bestimmt schon wieder vergessen habe,
aber irgendwann wird sich das halt so langsam ein und dann habe ich ja vor das eigentlich los ich glaube so vor zwei jahren,
zwei drei jahre ist das ist glaube ich ja dass ich mich überhaupt mal mehr auf diese youtube welt eingelassen habe,
also nicht dass ich nicht noch nie was auf youtube gesehen hätte vorher aber ich habe mir mal ein bisschen drauf eingelassen habe das alles mal so auf mich einprasseln lassen und habe auch irgendwie so mehrere nächte wochen,
mir so von der station zur region also dieses dieses ganze topic surfing und random watching und alles mal gemacht
und mich dann halt so auf sachen konzentriert die mich eben besonders interessiert habe weil sie brexit kram trump universum,
der ganze politische mumpitz aber dann eben auch ein zunehmenden maße space.
Einfach weil's so ein füllhorn an an wirklich interessanten zeug ist also ich bin einfach mehr denn je total,
überrascht wie viel neues geiles zeug da fast täglich rauskommt also man nimmt es ja immer so alle paar wochen mal vielleicht normalerweise war und solche sachen wie raum zeit,
mögen dann schon dazu führen dass manche leute da eine erhöhte frequenz haben aber man kann es auf jeden fall noch steigern und es gibt einfach ein paar richtig schicke youtube-kanäle,
und die wollte ich mal empfehlen falls ihr lust habt auch mal ein wenig auf space reise zu gehen so erklärbär,
mäßig das ist das schon mal gemacht hast du ja schon mal so weltraum erklärt zeug auf youtube angeguckt.
Das liegt aber daran dass ich einfach zu viel mit space zu tun hat mit der raketen heftchen serie als dass ich mich dann quasi auch noch mit der realen weltraum.
Verstehe du bist ja schon im fiction da nicht auch noch science.
Genau also ich bin so alle paar jahre gucke ich dann mal also für mich ist dieser moment dass die rakete nicht einfach zerstört wird was ich auch immer so ein traumatische,
traumatische idee von schon als kind fand ich das immer schlimm ein raumschiff darf man nicht zerstören,
wenn man mit ihm fliegen will das das muss man erhalten das ist was wertvolles ja das fand ich immer doof und deswegen konnte ich natürlich eher mit so einem space shuttle schon mal
irgendwie mich anfreunden weil da ja nur noch dieser tank der große geopfert wird und
das ist aber auch jetzt wieder so ein elon musk ich glaube immer machst ist einfach ein ganz ganz großer kids kopf der der genau die dinge macht
vor allem spätestens nimm zwölfjährigen sagen ach komm vergiss es werd mal erwachsen so ne so als stau ich hatte bei euch einfach ein loch wie was weiß ich bei raumschiff gigantisch ja von,
rolf kau kau es gab die schneider bücher da gab's irgendwie so eine welt also es war eine,
science-fiction serie wo man mit so erdbeertraum schiffen durch den magma kugel gefahren ist ziemlich abgefahrene kinder ist heinz fiction.
Sind immer ganz genau.
Raumschiff gigantisch.
Raumschiff giganten weil sie nichts drüber.
Und es ist halt total geil ich wäre so so ein art das brot aber in lava und er traumschiff giganten heißt das und.
Du deinen link dafür also du bist ja überhaupt rechner frei.
Bin rechner frei.
Ja das ist verstörend er traum.
Schiff gigantisch.
Kanto kannst du da mal gucken.
Ja ich bin dabei.
Ja und so macht das halt auch mit den raketen das kann ich ihnen rakete bauen mit allem drum und dran und dann fliegt er einmal hoch und ist zerstört nee wir retten die und dann fliegt ihr wieder und setzt auch,
richtig passgenau wie sich das gehört wie aus dem science fiction filmen wie es schon immer wahr und sein sollte setzt das jetzt auf,
und das war so ein moment wo ich wieder gedacht hab aha okay das sind jetzt echt einen schritt weiter das hat mich beeindruckt.
Mir ist auch klar warum das jetzt erst geht weil du jetzt erst die schnellen rechner systeme hast,
die quasi diese vier oder mehr triebwerke so synchronisieren können mehr tausendfach in der sekunde dass man halt wirklich das ding da gerade runter,
bringt dann gefunden.
Gigantomane werdet vorstoß in die erde.
Wie heißt denn der autor.
Rolf ulrike.
Rolf genau der hat ja auch noch raumschiff monitor und das war ein richtiges raumschiff und dann hat er quasi gesagt jetzt mache ich das selber aber mit in mit so einem raumschiff traumschiff halt cool finde ist dass es da nicht so,
das ist so ein ganz eigenes genre davon gibt's nicht so viel.
Schiff gigant.
Über uns ein vulkan ist schon irgendwie geile geile headline oder gleich artikel dass du unter einem vulkan so mit einem raumschiff so parkst.
Okay fertig.
Wer raumschiff gigant und ich kenne ich muss es unbedingt mal mal gelesen haben so als na.
Ich kann ja mal gucken ob man überhaupt an die bücher noch rankommt ich mein.
Hast du dich gerade da einen link geliebt.
Ja also es gibt noch gebraucht irgendwie aber das ist scheint eine reihe zu sein und manchmal ist das problem an so rein dass es dann halt irgendwie nur einzelne gibt genau.
Sieht aber ganz gut aus hier.
Zwei drei.
Meldet schiffbruch in der erde die frage ist nur bestellst du jetzt noch bevor ich die sendung raushaue oder danach.
Ich kann jetzt für die ich kann jetzt allerdings für die literarischer qualität überhaupt nicht mehr garantieren war.
Aha.
Ist halt jugend literatur kann man so einfach.
Ich glaube ich traue mich auch nicht so etwas zu lesen wieder weil ich einfach das gefühl habe dass es so killing mal ja also.
Kann schon sein,
okay kommen wir zu den neuen idolen die sich da anbieten im internet und ich habe ja hier auch nicht nicht nur einmal mein,
schwieriges verhältnis zu diesem etwas hektischer youtube beiträgen geäußert also es gibt so eine art darreichungsform bei youtube die ich jetzt überhaupt nicht mag,
aber es gibt ja auch die anderen.
So wie lars.
Sowie lars fischer zum beispiel genau aber es gibt auch noch andere und ich gebe euch jetzt mal ein paar tipps also meine allererste empfehlung ist,
dr becky,
doktor becky ist großartig eine astrophysikerin aus england ich weiß gerade gar nicht genau wo sie ist oxford genau in oxford ist sie,
und ist wirklich extrem
charming und berichtet irgendwie über alles mögliche hat so eine monatliche sendung so über die sky news wo sie dann eben wie das eben so astronomen gerne tun so was sind so gerade mal weltall
zu sehen ist wenn man jetzt selber mal ein teleskop blicken möchte oder sich einfach generell für konstellation interessiert aber,
davon abgesehen hat sie auch noch echt coole weitere beiträge was ich vielleicht mal konkret als einstieg empfehlen kann ist eine sendung die sie vor kurzem gemacht hat,
über die lichtgeschwindigkeit,
genau genommen sind es sogar zwei video nämlich wie man.
Das hier ist eine und das ist,
das andere wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche die links findet ihr in den shownotes und sie geht auch so diese ganze vergangenheit und das ist jetzt das selbe video ne,
wie zwei auf jeden fall sehr unterhaltsam,
hat immer text am ende was wo sie sich überall verhaspelt hat und oft fängt sie dann irgendwann auch einfach an zu singen,
super charming super nice ganz großes kino.
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen ich habe den schon schon gepostet an das eher mathematische pondon november pfeil oder also haben wir viel,
mit mit unter anderem hanna,
das ist auch seins mathematik lustig amüsant dargestellt ich mag hannah sowieso,
die hat jetzt auch grade zu weihnachten wieder die bibi bibi for christmas lectures gehalten die auch immer sehr sehr amüsant sind ich weiß aber nicht ob man da,
ohne irgendwie proxy rankommt,
also aus dem deutschen netz heraus weiß ich nicht ob man ob man an die christmas,
sendungen so einfach ankommt an einander fall auf jeden fall,
aber das spielt auch so ein bisschen in die richtung coole spannende lustige science in dem fall halt mathematik.
Okay ich bleibe jetzt nochmal bei space,
keine andere chance nochmal rübergehen wenn wir jetzt gerade in der youtube-channel empfehlungskarte sind dann gibt's noch einen menschen der mich ehrlich gesagt,
tal umhaut mit seiner produktivität der haut nicht weniger als jeden tag ein zehn minüter raus,
jeden tag heißt anton petrol scheint irgendwie,
russischer abstammung zu sein wohnt aber in kanada milch das richtig sehe ich glaube in montreal,
und kommentiert täglich so on camera,
aktuelle papers studien die grade rausgekommen sind oder andere ereignisse oder reagiert auch mal auf ein x c d comic wie jüngst gerade wo wir in einem x,
vorschläge gemacht werden für ein besseres sonnensystem was nicht so langweilig ist somit wir tun wir hier mal ein paar planeten rein und jupiter und saturn fassen wir mal zu einem zusammen und solche späße,
der macht das dann auch einfach mal weil das ist sehr cool er sitzt immer vor der kamera.
So in der ecke aber
neunzig prozent des greens werden sind sozusagen sein sein screen wo er immer live also ich weiß nicht ganz genau wie er es macht manchmal sind's irgendwie gelungene videos manchmal
macht er es auch interaktiv keine ahnung wie viel nachbearbeitung dann noch mit da drin ist
man sehr sieht auch immer sehr viele katzen zwischendurch also er spricht dann schon in der summe relativ flüssig aber man merkt es aus einzelnen text zusammengenommen ist
und er benutzt eine software die gibt es auf steam dass diese,
spiele online-plattform was ich mir,
erst jüngst nochmal ein bisschen genauer angeschaut habe das heißt diverse sandbox.
Universe sandbox ist so quasi eine echtzeit simulation von universe also,
du hast also die ganze das ganze universum drin also wie extensiv es ist weiß ich nicht aber sonnensystem ist auf jeden fall komplett gecovert und
du kannst dann halt so dir unsere planeten anschauen auf alles drauf klicken
reinzoomen in der zeit vor und zurück alles fliegt rum aber du kannst halt auch änderungen vornehmen kannst du irgendwie sorgen ja was denn jetzt wenn die erde ein bisschen weniger masse hätte oder sie schneller bewegt oder ist lass ich da mal mond drauf fallen oder in frieden oder so ich,
mal den mond zum maß und so diese ganzen sachen kannst du machen und dann läuft das halt wirklich simuliert weiter
keine ahnung chips die erde näher an die sonne ran und dann siehst du da so ja jetzt lassen wir das mal ein paar tausend jahre laufen und gucke mal jetzt ist es die ozeane verdampft und also,
also wirklich richtig cool und er benutzt halt diese software um das was er gerade erklärt das sind immer sehr aktuelle sachen
um das auch in irgendeiner form zu illustrieren oder teilweise auch wirklich zu erklären wirklich geil universität box ist wirklich nett und damit rumzuspielen,
ja anton petrol seit kanal heißt da mars,
video games aber er hat schon extrem fokus auf astronomische themen.
Ich kriege je mehr ich dir zuhören schon wieder lust elite jurist zu spielen,
ähm im prinzip ein weltall spiel wo du dir ein raumschiff kaufen kannst und damit dann durch die gegend fliegen und dinge von a nach b transportieren oder dir supernova angucken oder du stellst du einfach das,
all und hörst irgendwelche signale ab oder springst einfach wild durch die gegend und entdeckst neue planeten,
auch ein relativ altes spiel,
hallo.
Ist ist das quasi das elite von damals.
Die elite von damals in neu.
Ah ok.
Auch sehr sehr schönes,
spiel mit ja ich dachte immer so weltreise weltraum ist eher so konsumiere ich lieber in serien,
und nicht als computerspiele weil ich da andere sachen bevorzuge aber das ist schon echt nett.
Ich glaube das ist auch ein ding auf das der anton petrol irgendwie fährt weil ich und kürbis spaceprogramm ist ja so dass andere wo man sich so selber seine eigenen raketen zusammenbauen kann und sowas,
das.
Da hatte ich jetzt einen future moment in meiner früheren büro weg ist dann ein neuer freiberufler eingetreten und dann musste natürlich erklären was er sagt und ich baue planeten,
gucken wir anderen normal,
grafikdesigner illustratorinnen text leute oder sonst was denn etwas erstaunt auf diesen planeten und weltenbau,
und dann sagt er ja ihr habt bestimmt schon mal von unity gehört und,
alle anderen nicht ich hatte schon mal was davon gehört und da seht ihr mit drei d da hätte er quasi so eine art outtake also,
das hat halt eine offene programmierer stelle und er hat gerade ein welten editor entwickelt mit dem man
gerade für simulationsprofile wie elite das wäre halt ein festes genre da gibt es jährlich irgendwie ein paar hundert produktionen im spielbereich und die brauchen halt welten und er,
für die produktion solcher spiele hat er quasi ein hochspezialisierte editor entwickelt mit dem dann quasi so einen spieler studio wie elite.
Hier ist in dem fall ja.
Dann entsprechend welten in massenhaft und was natürlich auch wahrscheinlich,
und randomisierte für ihr spiegel-universum rausfallen lassen kann und der muss natürlich schon mal so die welten auch erstmal bauen ob die auch funktionieren und dann kann er die natürlich dann erst die paare
parameter quasi in so einem überführen und so dass das dann,
jesus leider hat man dann festgelegt das fand ich dann hochinteressant hinsichtlich der durchdringung arbeitsteilung ja prozesse in der gamesbranche
allerdings,
stellte sich heraus dass das der geschäftserfolg das business modell seines weltenbau editor dann doch noch ein bisschen schmal war,
aber fand ich.
Aber er hat die skills um dann per anhalter durch die galaxis weltenbau zu werden.
Auf jeden fall war das für mich auch schon mal wieder so ein so ein living die future moment dass jemand ganz ernsthaft halt sagt ich baue welten.
So wie's latin bad fass im anhalter,
ja das sind jetzt so ein bisschen meine meine top-tipps die sachen die ich irgendwie am,
liebsten sehe es gibt auch noch ein paar andere ganz interessante sachen je nachdem es gibt so relativ aufwendige gute kanäle wie zum beispiel astronom.
Sie haben vor allem sehr schöne mission zusammenfassung,
was wissen wir über was hat die und die mission am ende rausgebracht das ist für mich teilweise auch so für die recherche manchmal ganz ganz ganz gut schöne sachen dabei,
ja dann gibt's natürlich viel so wahr raumfahrt space-x alles mögliche leute die dann eben auch die gelegenheit nutzen in usa
diese ganzen orte veranstaltungen lounges zu fahren und mit den
leuten viel zu diskutieren da ist nicht unbedingt immer alles toll dabei ist mir dann auch teilweise schon wieder ein bisschen zu hektisch aber man kriegt da eben auch interessante informationen,
da nenne ich mal exemplarisch every day astronaut,
das ist eigentlich im wesentlichen so das was ich jetzt erstmal so aus der kalten empfehlen würde aber doktor becky ist muss shaming,
auf jeden fall.
Gut das mal zu dem space thema.
Was ist denn dein take gregor zum thema tesla und berlin.
Hallo.
Giga factory und was das mit uns tun wird.
Also erstmal ich war schon,
erstaunt welche unterwürfige reaktion ist in der deutschen öffentlichkeit hervorgerufen hat das,
tesla hier eine fabrik eröffnet also als wird auf einmal sternenstaub auf unser gebeutelten land herab regnen.
Ist ja auch so.
Ja aus tesla war sicht sieht das glaube ich aber anders aus.
Ja das könnte ich mir auch vorstellen.
Für tesla ist es quasi der gang in die höhle der löwen,
so ein bisschen würde ich mal sagen als ob sap mit seinem headquarter von heidelberg da von waldorf,
nach silicon valley gehen würde nicht dass ich nicht schon auch dort arbeiten würden aber quasi so eine wirklich massiven,
fußabdruck quasi in so einem bereich wo sie irgendwie mitspielen aber gleichzeitig auch noch was lernen können plus das natürlich hier in.
Berlin brandenburg ist jetzt nicht so total weit weg von anderen,
wichtigen automobil industriebereich also wolfsburg das ist eine stunde mit dem ice was für amerikanische verhältnisse einfach,
witz das ist eine bessere s-bahn genauso ist mit leipzig in leipzig hat bmw und porsche werke wenn man in dresden hat,
volkswagen wiederum werk ein bisschen weitergeht zwickau und zitter holt glaube ich chemnitz in der ecke gibt's auch weitere es geht bis nach eisenach mit uwe also quasi,
nur schon in ostdeutschland hast du quasi relativ viel in der überschaubaren umgebung einfach so eine so eine sich,
anwachsenden struktur von automobile,
kompetenz und die brauchst du in irgendeiner weise auch weil du musst ja irgendwie deine leute,
dazu bringen und dass sie sich dann für berlin entschieden hat liegt bestimmt auch nochmal daran dass es natürlich du kriegst relativ gut leute aus aller welt mal für eine zeit lang
nach berlin und das ist jetzt irgendwie grün heide oder so heißt ist natürlich von von außen gesehen dann ganz egal das ist dann berlin,
ich finde das finde ich ja also nachvollziehbar und.
Ich fand's erstaunlich dass es so eine reaktion gab weil mein eindruck war bisher immer dass in deutschland tesla systemisch unterschätzt wird,
und die diese überreaktion fand ich so ein bisschen peinlich weil er es war tesla quasi total unseriös und auf einmal jetzt wo ein werk hier in deutschland und vor allen dingen in berlin,
geplant ist da ist auf einmal ist es auf einmal alles ganz toll und ich finde es ja eher so ein so eine mischung zwischen ganz toll und komplett unseriös das ist ja auch so ein bisschen das problem von von tesla,
und ansonsten finde ich dass.
Wie das so ein bisschen testen kann man schon irgendwie vergleichen mit mit apple so was die was die,
die sicht von draußen auf tester anbelangt sich glaube bis zum,
bis zum iphone eigentlich war apple in dieser größeren und tech-welt keine so große nummer und,
das ist dann jetzt in den letzten fünfzehn jahren zu so einem riesen player herangewachsen ist das.
Das zeigt für mich so ein bisschen das potenzial was unter umständen bei tesla noch noch stattfinden also tesla ist geht ja momentan auch so diese börsen bewertung wo gesagt wird die sind mehr wert als,
fort und general motors zusammen,
und sind auf selber bewertungs- höhe wie volkswagen und volkswagen ist der größte automobilproduktion der welt und hat,
ich glaube das lag dreihundert oder vierhunderttausend autos ausgeliefert im zwanzig neunzehn,
und volkswagen elf millionen oder sowas und da wird es immer so diese beiden zahlen so gegeneinander gesetzt aber tesla und das sagt auch volkswagen selber tesla wird halt als tech-unternehmen bewertet,
und ist da eigentlich noch vergleichsweise kleines mit zweihundertfünfzig milliarden jetzt glaube ich,
apple hat eins komma vier millionen in us dollar glaube ich und es gibt dann noch so ein zwei weitere die über der billion dollar,
schwelle gekommen sind.
Microsoft.
Dennoch google.
Google das übliche.
Und ich glaube dass jetzt sind ja die ersten auch deutschen konkurrenz modelle raus,
auf dem markt und man kann jetzt mal wirklich so back-to-back die die sachen testen und man sieht dass tesla doch erstaunlich gut ist.
Man muss überlegen dass zum beispiel modell ist das erste wirklich funktionsfähige,
fahrzeug was man wird wirklich nutzen kann in der ersten generation ist es nach wie vor auf augenhöhe mit den mitbewerbern beziehungsweise in bestimmten bereichen auch überlegen da kommen muss man jetzt so,
überlegen was einem jeweils wichtig ist zum beispiel die die die verarbeitungsqualität ist halt wirklich mau ja also da,
wenn einem das bei einem bei einem luxusauto nicht stört dass die verarbeitungsqualität schlecht ist das ist aber ein bisschen ein teil von dem was luxus bedeutet dass es einfach
nicht knarzt dass irgendwie das leder nicht aussieht wie irgendwie speckig kunstleder also es ist zwar leder aber es sieht halt aus wie kunstleder und das sind einfach so sachen
das sind die die deutschen hersteller und natürlich wirklich auf einem ganz anderen level das ist jetzt für die pioniere der elektromobilität egal,
das wird aber irgendwann schon wenn man in den mainstream markt hineingeht ist spielt das eine rolle aber trotz all dieser mangos die tesla hat,
glaube ich dass die ähnlich wie apple so eine fähigkeit entwickelt haben zu überleben und,
das ist keine eintagsfliege es ist ja nicht so dass er,
die die pioniere waren und dann werden sie überrollt vom vom vom rest der automobilbranche sondern es wird umgekehrt sein tesla wird bleiben.
Und zwar als einer der ganz großen wirklich führenden hersteller bin ich mir sicher ins mitte der dreißiger jahre wird das tesla geben,
einige der heutigen großen weltweit führenden automobilhersteller wird es nicht mehr geben das ist so meine prognose die ich jetzt einfach mal,
so digger faktor in berlin brandenburg hin oder her einfach jetzt mal so wage.
Und hast du auch einen tipp wenn es nicht gibt.
Ja die fusionieren ja alle also zum beispiel von vier hat wird man nichts mehr hören nissan also die die.
Ist die frage firma oder marke also konzern oder marke.
Es ist ein bisschen schwierig weil die die werden niemand verschwindet einfach komplett wie wie,
in der welt finanzkrise da war es sind einfach verschwunden und und niemand hat sie gekauft es wird eher so sein dass sie in irgendwelchen
kameraden langsam aufgehen und da sind die ein oder andere fabrik aus welchen gründen auch immer dann in diesem konglomerat
weiter existiert so dass man da nicht so sagen kann die gibt's nicht mehr also diese,
dazu ist quasi das ganze diese ganze maschine die so ein so ein automobilhersteller mit seinen entwicklungsabteilungen mit seinem vertrieb mit der ganzen händler war dass es für sich so ein großer wert den man immer,
nutzen wird um ihn auszuschlagen achten um im quasi mit seiner eigenen neuen dna aufzufordern aber man sieht ja jetzt schon.
Opel ist von peugeot jetzt gekauft worden peugeot und,
genau peugeot hat citroen gekauft und situationen ist quasi als,
eigenständige marke gar nicht mehr erkennbar so mit eigener technologie,
wo sie früher so ganz ulkig lösungen angeboten haben das gibt's nicht mehr also insofern würde ich schon sagen zitrone ist nicht mehr existent und dasselbe wird,
bei landschaft und vielleicht bei alpha romeo auch passieren dass die in irgendeiner form vielleicht noch eine zeit lang so als markenband mitgeschleppt werden aber dann irgendwann abgestoßen werden.
Und bei den deutschen also ich habe ja gerade den eindruck dass,
diese ganze elektro nummer insbesondere von daimler benz offener episch epischen maßstab verkackt wird ich meine die haben nichts nichts gar nichts nichts.
Ja es ist so.
Und der einzige brand mit dem sie das jetzt versuchen es so überzeugend.
Also ich komischerweise habe ich so ein bisschen bmw ist für mich eigentlich eher die schwächste,
das schwächste glied weil,
daimler ist so groß wiederum auf internationalen parkett und wurde jetzt quasi von den die chinesen von gili,
mit zwanzig prozent so unterstützt sie können jederzeit,
wenn's daimler nicht so gut geht auf vierzig und einundfünfzig hochgehen und das dann einfach übernehmen und haben genug über den heimatmarkt um sich quasi dann daimler benz als,
edelmarke und perle in ihrem großkonzern zu halten da spielt das die jetzt mit ihrem ersten versuch.
Wer du meinst daimler wird gekauft.
Ist ja schon also es gibt ein ein ein hersteller der heißt der hat glaube ich auch noch volvo und.
Hab ich da was verpasst.
Ja die haben erstmal jetzt eine strategische minderheit beteiligung von zehn oder zwanzig prozent gekauft aber das heißt die sitzen jetzt an entscheidender stelle und die haben natürlich auch im chinesischen bereich,
einfluss das heißt daimler bands kann jetzt auf dem chinesischen markt,
hat sie auf einmal quasi ein sehr großen wichtigen player der auch natürlich das wohlwollen der staatsführung hat und wenn die da einfach mal sagen in peking,
könnt ihr keine autos mehr zugelassen bekommen dann kriegen sie auch keinen rat mehr auf die straße und wenn aber sagt nee.
Bringt ihnen mal was weiß ich tausend luxus klassen würden wir doch gerne in peking obwohl ansonsten die zulassungsbescheinigung zu sind also da öffnen sich einfach möglichkeiten auf beiden bereichen aber bmw hat halt niemanden bmw ist,
im weltweiten maßstab zu klein aber gleichzeitig auch natürlich nach wie vor zu gut und zu profitabel und niemand weiß,
mit wem bmw sich jetzt quasi noch verbünden sollte und die haben auch eine komische,
die sind ja zu früh mit ihren elektro,
angeboten gewesen und haben so ein bisschen quickie um die ecke gedacht nämlich dass sie das auto extrem teuer machen indem sie so kohle faser karossen und fahrgestell entwickeln,
um das auto leichter zu machen und damit quasi die batterie kosten zu lösen das ist wieder so ingenieurs denke und tesla hat einfach gesagt komm
egal schmeißen wir alles drauf und das erledigen wir über den leistungen und drehmoment unserer motoren interessiert sowieso keinen menschen und,
aber das sind nochmal jetzt wo jetzt wirklich die autos auf der straße sind merkt man wo einfach tesla zehn zwölf jahre vorsprung ein echter produkt.
Produkten auf der straße hat nämlich ihre batteriespeicherung ist halt software und ich glaube da liegt,
dieser dieses silicon valley ding ist die haben erst quasi eine software das als eine software herausforderung und dann erst eine batterie,
und chemische herausforderungen gesehen und ich glaube in für den deutschen hersteller war das erste erstmal die muss die zelle chemie stimmen und dann muss es gekühlt werden und dann dies
und zum schluss wird dann irgendeine arme sau draufgesetzt und soll das denn alles quasi software mäßig möglichst elegant aber in was weiß ich drei monaten zusammen.
Wie man jetzt auch bei vw so schön sehen kann jetzt haben sie all die drei schon so kurz vor shipping und da können aber noch nicht mal einen online-shop update machen.
Genau das ist einfach noch in dieser ganzen denke noch nicht drin dass das lernen die jetzt den den harten weg und ich halte das rennen deswegen auch noch für unentschieden weil
im klassischen bereichen haben natürlich die deutschen hersteller nach wie vor ein vorteil,
und tesla hat quasi andere unkonventionelle dinge die für für so ein pionier publikum super sind aber fürs mainstream publikum glaube ich nicht so interessant noch nicht erreicht,
und jetzt der tim weg den wollte ich das habe ich jetzt habe ich die jetzt die ganze zeit auf tim,
zu eingequetscht.
Ich bin nicht weg ich habe zugehört aber ich brauchte noch ein bier.
Ja und,
aber ich will jetzt mal sagen also die was ich in den letzten jahren immer so dachte oh das wird eine wacklige geschichte wackelige nummer mit tesla und ich glaube die sind jetzt durch die die haben's jetzt wirklich geschafft,
und werden bleiben da hätte ich vor zwei jahren noch nicht so 'ne sichere prognose gewagt.
Also da war ich mir eigentlich relativ sicher schon vor zwei jahren ich glaube das ist auch so zwei drei jahre her,
hier das erste mal so richtig drüber gequatscht haben als clemens ich glaube ich auch seinen tessa gekauft hat so die zeit,
und ich meine mich zu erinnern mich zu so 'ner aussage durchgerungen zu haben zu sagen so,
warte mal ab das dauert jetzt noch zwei drei jahre und dann ist der ding durch,
das war noch so diese phase so wird elektro wirklich was werden und es sind ja nur jetzt hier so diese show auf fahrzeuge aber es will ja keiner und der diesel und überhaupt die verbrenner fahren ewig weil es glaube ich a
mental ist diese diskussion jetzt tatsächlich beendet also,
sich jetzt keiner mehr hin und sagt das wird nicht kommen es klar dass einfach batterie fahrzeuge das ding sind.
Der system das haben wir die deutschen hersteller die konventionellen nicht gerafft weil die immer schon aussieht auf tankstellen seit uhrzeit sich verlassen können,
tesla hat halt gewusst wir müssen halt unser eigenes netzwerk noch bauen damit wir die dinge,
zum laufen bekommen und die damit haben sie einfach dieses ständige henne ding gelöst,
das haben die deutschen hersteller noch nicht und.
Und werden auch noch richtig probleme haben das zu lösen weil mit diesem merkwürdig aufgeteilt
markt hier mit ladesäulen betreiber hier und netzwerken da und tausend verschiedene
und verschiedene lade-systeme und hier ist es so und so viel und keine einheitliche publikation der der daten wo du opladen kannst oder ob
das funktioniert oder ob du aber platz ist oder ob da nicht wieder irgendein bekloppter verbrenner davor steht und das hat irgendwie tesla wirklich sehr elegant gelöst.
Und das ist halt auch wieder was apple dann auch gemacht hat dass sie quasi in verschiedenen bereichen sich quasi du willst,
digitale musik-player verkaufen,
da muss es halt irgendwie einen weg geben dass man auch was zu hören hat auf diesem digitalen musik-player und dann haben sie nebenbei eher mal die das kreuz das größte musik distributions netz entwickelt,
und diese das ist so eine,
ich sag mal so eine silicon valley denke und die fehlt natürlich in diesen traditionellen geschäftsvorstellung der deutschen und auch viele anderen herkömmlichen,
automobilhersteller völlig und das wird noch ein richtiges problem werden.
Dafür dass er fehlt wirklich alles also ich weiß ich war in barcelona auf dieser messe und da hatte irgendwie mercedes und stand und da hatten sie diese furchtbaren wie heißen die kuh xxl.
Also da muss man auch mal sagen dass es einfach schon bestehendes modell da wurde quasi auf die schnelle eine elektrifizierung rein gekloppt.
Klar aber das ist ja nicht das was ich meine das ding ist du setzt dich da nur rein und die ganze system sprache ist,
hallo ich bin's dein kompliziertes out,
was du nicht bedienen kannst knöpfe und buttons und menüs und unter menüs von unter menüs und es ist einfach alles so du sitzt da und denkst ja nur so was zur,
hölle was ihnen irgendwie,
über hundert jahre perfekt gelungen ist diese idee von auto ist drei pedale ein lenkrad,
hebel vielleicht noch und das ist alles was du wissen musst um irgendwie mit zweihundertfünfzig sachen.
Gegen baum zu fahren.
Gegen baum zu fahren durch die gegend also voranzukommen und ein paar hebel vielleicht noch und,
kaum dass das sozusagen diese diese ganze elektronik beziehung kam ja ist alles frei gedreht und du kannst irgendwie nichts in deutschland richtig benutzen alles und ich sage dir auch eins,
ein grund warum das in europa und speziell in deutschland immer noch nicht läuft ich weiß leute wer mich jetzt hassen für diese aussage,
aber ich sehe einfach zu viele beispiele auch bei diesem bekloppten hotel wo ich war zu viele menschen die zu viel zeit mit windows verbracht haben.
Hallo.
Das meine ich wirklich tot ernst einfach wer sich lange in diesem windows aussetzt kann kein geschmack entwickeln das ist einfach das geht nicht,
da bekommst du einfach die ganze zeit nur gezeigt wie es nicht laufen sollte und das ist das was du lernst,
und alle leute sitzen hier in diesen büros und vor diesem system und diesem wort und diesen ganzen eigenen wahnsinn ich meine dein notpack plus plus was mir eben gezeigt hast in allen ehren aber ich schaue mir nur diesen,
die bar von diesem film mit disketten und so weiter an ja und ich weiß einfach dass ich mich davon sehr sehr sehr weit entfernt werden weil das nicht gut für mein für mein karma ist.
Für den kreislauf folgen.
Das auch,
und das sehe ich halt auch in diesen ganzen mercedes vw bmw auch mit ihren knöpfen und so weiter leute wirklich was macht ihr da,
das ist einfach nicht schön ihr zeigt mir einfach direkt dass ihr das alles gar nicht verstanden habt was dieser computer eigentlich für einen tun sollte und dass dass dass dass es nicht
engineering ist und dass dass ihr da eine maschine baut und dann muss man nur lernen mit der maschine umzugehen sondern es muss einfach von von mir ausgedacht.
Ich stelle mir grade so einen kleinen clip in dem tesla vor guten tag und ich bin da hinfahren ich singe sie möchten irgendwie an die tankstelle darf ich ihnen behilflich sein.
Sowas wird auch noch kommen so ja und tesla gewinnt mit software mit mit,
infrastruktur großer punkt ne ich meine das ist das ding und ich ich denke jetzt schon seit längerem drüber nach so okay alles klar wie werde ich jetzt meinen letzten verbrenner los,
die ich jetzt noch habe war klar wir können uns darüber diskutieren brauchst du wirklich ein auto tim und so geschenkt.
Wir wissen alle dass dass das nicht jetzt von heute auf morgen ist das alles sagen so ach ja welt retten so auto weg findet nicht statt sondern viele werden sich diese frage auch stellen,
und dann gucke ich mir die ganzen modelle an und gut ich habe jetzt so meine kriterien und anhängerkupplung da liegt ja schon mal neunzig neunundneunzig prozent des marktes komplett raus so aber ich weiß halt auch so,
tesla koffer dann werde ich überall hinfahren können es wird immer strom geben,
und das ist so durchgeplant und das auto weiß auch wo es hin muss und einfach,
of my mind es ist quasi schon mit eingepreist und schon mal locker zwanzig prozent des kaufpreises den den ich bereit bin zu akzeptieren einfach nur weil das so ist,
oder bei den anderen dingern würde ich noch nicht mal weiß so mit welchen,
bekloppten karten und unsicheren systemen kann ich jetzt überhaupt an welcher ladesäule wann sicher ist einfach
das erzeugt einfach diese diese reichweiten angst sondern so dieses das versprechen des automobils dir jederzeit mobilität bereitzustellen,
das ist nicht mehr gegeben damit.
Vor allen dingen dann auch so ein bisschen so ein modul hast dass das auto ist ja verkauft und wie du deinen strom bekommst dass jetzt dein problem so.
Egal selber schuld.
Und und das ist macht schon einen unterschied wenn du quasi einen tesla fährst und dann auch noch deine tesla tankstelle nicht den strom liefert den sie soll weil dann.
Da hast du eine adresse an die dich die du aber auch nicht erreichst das muss man auch sagen dass,
dass kein besonderes,
so wirklich exzessiv kundendienst und all das was man so kennt bei so einem hochpreisigen wichtigen produkt also ich glaube im moment wenn das hier so,
so die nerds die ich so,
kenne und mit deren einstellung ist es natürlich teurer das sind leute die natürlich erstmal alles selber fixen bevor sie sich mit irgendeinem
kundendienst so eine schnittstelle aufmachen wollen ja da das federt ja eine menge ab in deiner in deiner organisation aber
je stärker dass in den massenmarkt hineingeht müssen natürlich irgendwie auch mal bisschen zugänglicher werden also,
wenn du irgendwas ein problem hast musst du eine e-mail schicken in so einem form template also da hat man immer das gefühl dass man nach nirvana sendet,
ich halte es also nur noch mal so das.
Es gibt ja so so ein paar aussagen die sagen deutschland ist dumm diese ganze automobile kerninfrastruktur ist kurz vor der schmelze und wir werden alle sterben,
nicht weil die deutsche automobilindustrie keine autos mehr produziert das glaube ich nicht,
sondern die wird wenn überhaupt werden die deutschen überleben und viele andere im rest der welt werden werden probleme bekommen also die amerikaner,
die japaner sind auch nicht besonders gut aufgestellt aus meiner sicht und ansonsten gibt's auch nicht mehr so viel bei den chinesen kann ich's nicht beurteilen.
Das was man so sieht ich war auf der ideale das war jetzt die letzte ihr in frankfurt das war echt schon eine ganz schöne toten totengräber stimmung aber da waren halt so doch eine reihe von diesen,
ja dieses pop-up shiny automotive bands von denen sie nie gehört hast,
die schon irgendwie ein bisschen so aussahen von dem was sie da so hingestellt haben,
aber das ist halt klar dass es so ein,
alle fangen mit als japaner ihre ersten produkte auf den markt gebracht haben oder die koreaner da haben wir auch einmal erstmal alle gelacht und man muss wirklich da viele jahre rein investieren audi hat,
ist,
zwanzig fünfundzwanzig jahre gebraucht um quasi auf augenhöhe mit,
bmw und mercedes zu kommen und das ist tesla quasi mit seinem ersten modell aus dem stand heraus geschafft hat in den neutralen,
märkten die innerhalb kürzester zeit die in diesem luxus premiumbereich die der führende anbieter zu werden das war für die für die deutschen,
absolut absoluter schock weil die das das war ihr kerngeschäft da hatten sie alles entsprechend im griff und das haben sie wohl,
ich finde das ja auch teilweise recht schnell reagiert haben weil.
Diese industrie hat so ein so ein so ein sieben jahreszeit und sie haben in der mitte des des zyklus also wenn man zwotausendzwölf,
das modell auf dem markt und dann haben sie sich das eine zeit lang angeguckt,
nach dem motto ist das jetzt eigentlich so blöd werff fahren die dinger wirklich gibt's die,
es gibt ja viele das war ja vorher nicht klar vorher war gab es auch schon tesla aber das war nur dieser kleine roadstar in wirklich,
ich weiß nicht fünf tausender auflage oder sowas auf jeden fall quasi aus aus deren normaler industriesicht war das eine boutique bastler shop,
und.
Jetzt das quasi in in schön zu machen mit einer großen limousine hätte immer noch im bastler shop sein können also das mussten die dann auch erstmal realisieren dass das wirklich ein erfolg ist und in dem moment in der halbzeit,
haben sie als sie gemerkt haben nach zwei drei jahren das ding ist wirklich hat substanz und ist ein gamechanger,
mussten sie dann alle ihre pläne hektisch ändern und dann kommen halt solche merkwürdigen,
visa heraus nach dem motto wir müssen jetzt irgendwie in diesem markt ein fuß drin haben sonst sind wir komplett unglaubwürdig das ding da,
dann kommt noch hinzu viele elektroautos wurden bis zwanzig zwanzig zurückgehalten weil erst ab zwanzig zwanzig die elektroautos,
verrechnet werden können mit den verbrennern um dann quasi die gesamt flotten quote unter diese geforderte eu quote zu senken und das könnte den quasi
viele millionen sparen deswegen haben sie quasi autos im letzten jahr auf den markt gebracht aber dafür gesorgt dass keines wirklich verkauft wurde,
also das.
Geht nicht verkaufszahlen geht's nur nach modellen.
Nein es geht jetzt auch nach verkaufszahlen das heißt quasi mit einem verkauften e-auto kannst du quasi kompensieren wenn du entsprechend eine verbrenner verkaufst und,
mit den verbrennern willst du ja dein geld verdienen und wenn dann quasi die strafzahlung so hoch ist dass du quasi deine normale rendite gar nicht mehr erwirtschaften kannst da war das für die,
bei so einem kleinen teil markt der der elektromobilität zwanzig neunzehn noch war haben sie gesagt jetzt halten wir das lieber zurück,
und selbst diesen diesen porsche drei kam der schon offiziell gelautet letztlich kriegst du den auch jetzt erst in diesem jahr überhaupt werden die ausgeliefert und zugelassen und dann,
nicht kaufvertrag sondern erstzulassung ist dann entsprechend das ding deswegen gab es jetzt so berichte ja ist der totale flop weil in zwanzig neunzehn wurden nur fünfhundert
stück zugelassen das liegt jetzt nicht nur an schwierigkeiten und dem komischen sondern da bin ich sicher
da haben sie sich quasi das haben die absichtlich verzögert weil es jetzt für die richtig wertvoll ist ein e-auto im markt zu haben verkauft es.
Hallo natalie du hast kein auto war.
Ich nix auto weder führerschein noch auto noch irgendwie kann ich damit für anfangen.
Wie kommst du denn so vorwärts.
Öffentliche verkehrsmittel weil ich den luxus habe in einer großstadt zu leben.
Aber hast du den eindruck dass du mit öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln in dieser großstadt immer so gut voran kommst.
Also das kann ich bestätigen ich glaube die.
Die sache ist halt ich habe keine familie ich habe kein kind ich muss kein großeinkauf für die ganze familie machen ich habe keine älteren angehörigen die ich irgendwie durch durch die gegend schiffen muss und dadurch klar für mich persönlich funktioniert,
öffentliche verkehrsmittel aber,
ich kann es auch absolut verstehen und akzeptieren dass andere personen diesen luxus halt nicht haben und dementsprechend auf ein auto angewiesen sind,
für mich ist es gerade ich werd mir irgendwann einen führerschein zulegen müssen,
oder aus rationalität einen zulegen weil ich gerne motorradführerschein machen möchte und bevor ich ein motorrad fahren sollte sollte ich vielleicht mal im auto gesessen haben.
Könnte hilfreich sein ja.
Ja damit man so ein gefühl für die straße kriegt und so.
Vor allem für autofahrer.
Ich glaube mein rad fährt hat man eigentlich das wichtige fürs motorrad fahren schon drin und sich auch mal an die regeln hält beim radfahren und dann lernt man vieles was einem beim motorradfahren auch noch hilfreich.
Aber alleine schon wie man aus dem auto radfahrer und motorradfahrer wahrnimmt ist nochmal eine eine wichtige information denke ich so,
aber das ist halt ich habe gerade andere sachen auf der roadmap zum beispiel so promotion und vorher.
Das emotionale beim automobil wird,
viel zu stark unterschätzt und wird quasi weil es zu viele leute das auch gar nicht zugeben wollen wird es so so zweck rationalisiert,
ich glaube man braucht kein auto ich glaube die kosten für ein auto,
wenn man aufm land lebt wann braucht man mal einen transport für größere sachen dann könnte man auch mit dem taxi wenn man die gesamtkosten wertverlust für ein auto das sind ja viele tausend euro das sind bestimmt sechs,
also selbst wenn mittelklasse-auto mit wenn du 'ne gesamt kostenrechnung hat sechstausend euro für taxi,
da bist du aber gut dabei das heißt siebzehn euro jeden tag oder so,
und dann im sommer kann man auch mal eine tour mit dem rad machen oder mal also selbst auf dem land das ist alles,
autofahren finde ich ist diese version mit dieser maschine und quasi teil dieser maschine zu werden und dann,
wahnsinnige multiplikation der körper fähigkeiten zu erlangen das ist die faszination.
Zu einem gewissen grad natürlich so dieses emotional auch diese diese flexibilität zu haben aber so wie die landstriche derzeit ausgestattet sind,
man auch mit einem taxi nicht die flexibilität die man eigentlich gerade bräuchte um land leben überhaupt zu ermöglichen weil alleine schon,
man muss ja regelmäßig zur arbeit kommen man muss regelmäßig einkäufe machen man muss wenn man familie hat die irgendwie durch die gegend das,
derzeit nicht mit dem schlecht ausgebauten nahverkehr und es geht auch nicht mit taxis und das interessante ist gerade auf dem land ältere bevölkerung die werden derzeit alle mit taxis,
zur zur nahversorgung also krankenhäusern oder oder arztpraxen,
also das heißt du musst dort teilweise eine woche zwei wochen vorher irgendwie ein taxi buchen weil alle taxis einfach mit krankenhaus fahrten und mit patienten fahrten aus,
gelagert sind weil's halt nichts anderes gibt und deshalb.
Was es komischerweise gibt es gibt überall auf dem land weiß nicht ob das jetzt das ländliche land ist dass man sich so vorstellen kann aber ich war jetzt öfters mal also
schon das war so land das ist nicht mal in die kirche in dieser gemeinde gab und das ist eigentlich schon gar nicht möglich ja es war siedlung aufm berg und ich kriege,
an jeder stelle,
kann ich mir über delivery oder lieferando tausend gerichte liefern lassen,
ja dann können die auch noch nebenher in huber betreiben und leute können muss ja nicht immer nur so eine dampfender pizza im auto rumfahren da können sie auch noch leute transportieren also und dafür sind ja.
Von welchem land redest du denn jetzt ohne kirche.
Ich will ja nicht so viel privates preisgeben wie hast du den podcast das du hast du musstest du darf.
Ich wusste ja nicht dass das jetzt privat ist.
Ist auch nicht so schlimm nur ich hab da ich hab da erfahrung wie das ist auf dem land oder ist,
da fährt auch wirklich nur diese sprichwörtlich zweimal am,
bus also ich weiß wie sich das anfühlt bis zum nächsten real hätte es dann,
wo man laufen würde ist das so als würde man jetzt von hier tim zum alexanderplatz laufen na ja also mit dem rad wäre das auch schon machbar ja also und dann.
Also ich glaube auch dass autos auf dem land nicht das problem sind.
Ja es wird nein mir geht's dann nochmal vom,
ich finde das bei bei bei tala so so interessant weil das einfach eine sphäre von von von erleben dass ihr komplett,
fremd ist ja also so ein auto selber zu fahren und irgendwann quasi mit dem auto so vertraut zu sein dass du gar nicht mehr weiß dass du auto fährst weil quasi alles was man tut zu so einer körper erweiterung führt und das ist ein ein,
finde ich nach wie vor ist es der,
eigentlich das kerngeschäft dessen was autos ausmacht alles wenn autos quasi zum pendeln benutzt werden das sind eigentlich sollte man das nicht machen,
weil,
autofahren sollte quasi dieser genuss finde ich dieser dieser version sein das ist das ist der kern des des des autofahrens und es gibt quasi auto hat nichts mit mobilität und.
Und verkehr zu tun das ist meine,
steile these sondern im kern geht es quasi um dieses diese faszination der der körper vervielfältigen oder körper extension
und deswegen ist es auch so ein so ein so ein emotionales thema deswegen reagieren die leute so empfindlich darauf weil es von,
allen seiten tabuisiert wird weil die sowas wie adac und die hersteller die versuchen quasi das automobil zweck grad zu
zu rationalisieren weil keiner letztlich zugibt außer bei bmw die freude am fahren in ihren claim reintun aber letztlich das auch nicht mehr leben keiner gibt es wirklich zu dass es eigentlich ein reines spaß maschine ist so.
Aber das finde ich nicht in der diskussion sollten autos abgeschafft werden oder nicht sondern das finde ich eher in der diskussion sollte man schneller als hundertdreißig stundenkilometer fahren,
das ist das ist das sehe ich dort eher in der in der diskussion auto ja oder nein da ist mehr rationalität drin weil es gibt halt einfach,
verschiedene listen von probleme das ist nicht nur dieses irrationale ich fahre gerne auto und deshalb möchte ich mein auto nicht abgeben.
Es ist eine absolute killer maschine jedes jahr werden anderthalb millionen menschen durch autos getötet,
weltweit weil es gibt irgendwie zweieinhalb milliarden autos und die werden auch zum teil gefahren,
und dabei passieren dinge heute mit unserem heutigen verständnis ist das eine technologie die man auf eine breite bevölkerung in so einer form überhaupt nicht mehr loslassen würde,
das muss man einfach mal so sagen also wir haben heute eine andere risiko horizont und nur noch dinge die es dies gibt.
Sind quasi eingepreist alles was neues wird quasi unter unter
komplett neue risikobewertung viel strenger beurteilt als das was schon da ist und wenn du heute so etwas wie ein auto erfunden würde und es noch keine gäbe oder derselbe duktus herrschen wäre
dann würden so viele autos fahren wie es helikopter lizenzen gibt und.
Also nochmal aber es ist total interessant weil es gibt halt einen steigenden teil von von von menschen wie du die den großen städten leben die sich,
ab einem bestimmten punkt einfach,
ob nun aus finanziellen oder aus brauche ich nicht das interesse oder verschiebe ich auf später da brauche ich entschieden haben nicht mal die fahrlizenzen zu machen das viel wichtiger die sind quasi,
fast verloren aber das ist eine ganz ganz wichtige einflussgröße von von leuten die heute politik machen,
für die politik gemacht wird und dadurch steht das auto absolut in in so einer kritik weil wenn du diesen emotionalen,
benefit niemals gespürt hast selber im im im auto,
gefahren zu sein und diese dieses dieses spezielle körpergefühl zu gefühl zu haben kann man kann man es nicht nicht verstehen dann sieht man nur die beschwernisse die risiken die die die,
die wirklich auch unerträglichen begleiterscheinungen weil man.
Stehe ich ganz anders gegenüber weil ich natürlich quasi immer noch diese dieses ideal habe und dann quasi die ganzen beschwernisse irgendwie,
zu tolerieren ja aber ich kann es total gut verstehen dass jemand wie du zum beispiel sagst sie nicht nur ich dulde das nicht oder ich nicht tolerieren sondern dass ich ganz klar verstehe dass viele leute das auto inzwischen ablehnen zumindest in den städten.
Aber,
das wird deine argumentationsweisen würde für mich sinn ergeben wenn ich diese komplette ich bin gegen autos haltung hätte was ich aber nicht bin sondern ich habe genug anderen leuten zugehört und,
verstehe den standpunkt und deshalb bin ich persönlich nicht anti auto,
sondern wir müssen den weg finden dass die person auf dem land damit klarkommen und dass wir aber die probleme in den städten lösen und das mache ich einfach indem ich anderen leuten zuhöre das ist halt dann.
Da will ich es anders sagen wenn ich du wäre wäre ich absolut natürlich gegen auto weil ich deine versammelt wie kann es,
was für eine zumutung so viel mich kinetische energie,
meistens in in form von schwachen charakteren hinterm lenkrad tue ich auf hunderttausende von ungeschützten anderen personenkreise.
Mal jemand an die kinder.
Ja es ist es ist ein unding es ist eine eine eine anomalie und,
ich kann's absolut verstehen und die zukunft des autos wird etwa da sein wo heute der reitsport mit pferden ist,
in fünfzig jahren wird es zwar noch autos geben wie wir das kennen aber die werden in wesentlich eingeschränkter maße noch herumfahren können frei und es wird ein bestimmter prozentsatz von leuten geben die
aber autos mögen und vor allen dingen diese
das autofahren in einer bestimmten form lieben und für die wird es in irgendeiner form spezialisierte bereiche geben wo sie das machen können.
Es gibt keine autobahn mehr.
Wenn es ein alter wenn es alternative transportmöglichkeiten gibt die das auto ablösen wie das auto das pferd abgelöst hat dann würde das,
auto zu einer reinen freizeit sportaktivität werden.
Ja weiß nicht da gehe ich nicht so mit ich denke,
wir werden einfach auf der infrastruktur die wir haben noch ganz andere konzepte sehen,
also so eine paket vermittlung von transport wär jetzt auch nicht das aller schlechteste also so orte erreichen und vor allem auch so soziales leben also für mich persönlich war ja das auto damals,
da habe ich den führerschein gemacht war das achtzig achtundachtzig genau da hatte ich dann auch vom staat wächst und allen gebrauchten golf und für mich war das halt damals,
sozial ein unfassbarer aufstieg also das hat mich in die lage versetzt.
Andere leute zu bewegen zu besuchen damit habe ich die ersten jahre im wesentlichen verbracht leute mitzunehmen,
bin wie ein bekloppter jedes mal damals war ja auch diese
züge flüge also dieses reisen in andere städte war ja auch nicht so billig wie jetzt,
da finde ich hat das auto jetzt schon extrem verloren also so auto benutzen ja aber mit dem auto in eine andere stadt fahren ist schon etwas wo ich echt viel länger drüber nachdenken als noch vor zwanzig jahren,
weil es einfach der ganze stress und autobahnen überhaupt wer will sich denn das geben und so klar wenn.
Züge mehr züge mehr nachtflüge.
Klar mehr zeuge vor allem mehr nachtsüber nachzügler können wir auch nochmal quatschen aber nichtsdestotrotz war damals ist auch ein extremes soziales erlebnis weil da gab's ja noch richtig viele tramper,
du bist ja heute auch fast nicht mehr da bisschen erstens durch so eine so eine komische para mit der böse tramper will ich überfallen so das war so das eine und dann kam so die mitfahrer gelegenheiten und.
Viel schlimmer der kaut ab und erzählt dir was von der afd und der umvolkung.
Ja gut sagen wir mal so wenn du heute noch trepper mitnimmst und es ist eigentlich.
Afd.
Der die hat da selber viel zu viel angst vor sich und,
ja aber ich habe das kann man sich gar nicht mehr vorstellen also ich weiß noch als ich nach immer ich bin viel nach berlin so hamburg berlin das das war eine strecke die ich sehr oft gefahren bin und,
wenn du berlin verlassen hast.
So quasi an den grenzen die dann keine mehr waren so hier so nach hannover raus auch hier hieß es da unten drei drei linden oder eben nach norden raus hier an der prenzlauer leo,
da standen immer zehn zwanzig dreißig leute mit gepäck die mitgenommen werden wollten.
Was war dein facebook.
Das war unser aller facebook aber das kann sich auch noch dran erinnern oder diese zeit das war einfach so es war einfach
heimlich viele leute
die da waren und ich bin halt jede ausfahrt raus und jede tankstelle bin ich immer durchgefahren um zu gucken ob da nicht auch noch einer steht auf der autobahn habe die leute einfach eingesammelt und aber immer mit dem rein raus und so und es war einfach super diese diese permanente
wechselnde interaktion und dann eben und das kommt dann auch nochmal so ein bisschen mit dazu das auto ist auch eine eine einmalige extrem intime,
situation für manche sicherlich auch bedrohlich aber grundsätzlich,
nett eingerichtetes auto irgendwie gutes gespräch ja bis er so abgekapselt im wahrsten sinne des wortes und irgendwie findet man sofort,
interessante gespräche toren die man jetzt in der bahn selten also.
Als ich so in das alter von von reisen aber möglichst preisgünstige kommen gab's dann halt mitfahrgelegenheiten mitfahrzentrale so die richtung,
wo du dann einmal bin ich von berlin nach münchen in der stretch limo,
der hat dann sechs leute eingesammelt und ist irgendwie halt nach münchen runter damit und manchmal hattest du halt wirklich so eine so eine großraumtaxi bis die maximal voll beladen waren und dann irgendwie einzelne studenten,
also das war dann nicht mehr mit trampen sondern mit vorankündigung und geld bezahlen aber es hat auch halbwegs funktioniert,
bin dann jetzt aber doch ganz froh dass ich mir irgendwie ein flixbus oder halt ein zug leisten kann.
Tim und ich wir sind irgendwie so so halbwegs großstadt aufgewachsen so metropolitan,
und was würdest du so schätzen in unserer generation neunzig fünfundneunzig prozent haben führerschein gemacht,
und jetzt bin ich mir sicher bei heute leute die in berlin leben und vielleicht auch in spandau autos götze bedient schon sorry,
vielleicht potsdam bei den,
achtzehnjährigen bis zwanzigjährigen vielleicht der eine sagt na ja erst nach dem abitur ist mir zu viel stress oder so ja das ist vielleicht noch sechzig fünfzig vielleicht sogar nur vierzig prozent in bestimmten bereichen.
Je weiter du aufs land kommst desto höher die quote.
Gut aber da leben halt nicht mehr so viele menschen die quote zu hoch aber in absoluten zahlen ist es dann nicht mehr so dolle aber überleg mal was das für einen einbruch an käufer schafft für die,
autohersteller das bedeutet die sehen ja diese zahlen schon und sie können nämlich mehr gegensteuern sie versuchen das ist jetzt so ein bisschen zu retten dass sie auch sagen okay wir machen aus dem auto sowas wie ein rollendes smartphone und,
damit wird diese soziale gedanke wieder dieses connect connectet also verbundenheit wieder,
hochgebracht also aber eigentlich pick automobil,
in unserer gesellschaft der der ist schon wahrscheinlich zwanzig jahre her.
Also ich habe ja mal kurz gegoogelt und anzahl der person in deutschland die einen pkw-führerschein besitzen von zwanzig sechzehn bis neunzehn interessanterweise steigende zahlen.
Korrigiert gegen einwohnerzahlen oder nur absolut werte.
Das was meinst du mit korrigiert.
Na ja du hast ja eventuell steigende einwohnerzahlen weil also dass das eine wogegen du rente kritisch korrigieren müsstest ist es die bevölkerung wird ja immer älter,
du hattest immer mehr personen ab achtzehn,
rein theoretisch müsstest du die zahlen der personen die einen führerschein haben quasi als als,
prozent errechnen gegen die person die einen führerschein haben könnten.
Als visualisierung und daten expertin fange ich jetzt überhaupt nicht mit dir zu diskutieren sondern ich zeige dir einfach diesen bekloppten link auf den ich jetzt gerade gelaufen bin.
Da hast du den tim ja gleich den zahn gezogen taler.
Nee ich wollte ich wollte es ihm nur erklären.
Du hast ja total recht aber ich muss ja leider nur sagen der link den ich jetzt gerade gefunden habe ist einfach eine umfrage und von daher ohnehin schon mal und es ist auch ein wenn du mehr wissen willst dann klick hier und bezahl.
Statistiker.
Kann ich dir da jetzt gerade gar nicht bedienen
das war jetzt so ein erster vergeblicher versuch der hat aber zumindest mal so eine zahl aber nicht in prozent so weil hier haben wir irgendwie sechsundfünfzig millionen ungefähr zu vierzehn mal so grob gesagt.
Siebenundfünfzig millionen von dreiundachtzig millionen menschen die in deutschland leben das ist jetzt mal.
Nein von.
Sechsundfünfzig.
Siebzig millionen die in dem richtigen alter sind auch.
Achso okay war ein paar junge.
Brauchst jetzt fünfjährige brauchst du jetzt nicht zu befragen ob sie einen führerschein haben so.
Trotzdem sind die gar nicht so viele wie ich gedacht hätte.
Ja also wir sind auch unkorrigiert werde vermutlich macht's keinen so großen unterschied nur ist in dem vorschaubild sieht man ein bisschen kannst du nochmal kurz hochscrollen.
Ich scroll selber im.
Also ich glaube jedenfalls ins auto hat seine zukunft schon hinter sich und alles was da noch kommen wird werden,
so spielzeuge und transport kapseln werden,
aber das auto wie wir es kennen das,
wird und ich spreche jetzt in fünfzig jahren also aber ich habe nun autos die sind,
fast alle über fünfzig jahre alt also deswegen für mich ist das nicht so ein so ein langer zeitraum auf über fünfzig jahre und die sind sind ja noch aus meiner alten autos die fahren ja noch und das ist.
Ja gut aber ich sage mal die die zahl die jetzt hier aus dieser umfrage grob rausfällt ist achtzig prozent derjenigen die sie haben können.
Gut aber mich interessiert die der die achtzehn bis vierundzwanzig jährigen ja und da würde mich mal die quote interessieren weil die die ist glaube ich,
für jemanden in der automobilindustrie beängstigend baut ich,
da wünscht er sich ganz schnell autonome autos die man verkaufen kann an leute die auch keinen führerschein haben ich glaube das.
Andererseits könnte man jetzt argumentieren ja junge leute sind nicht die kaufkraft und wir fokussieren uns einfach auf reiche alte männer.
Aber das ist ja ein endliches geschäftsmodell.
So lange es kurzfristig funktioniert und die roten zahlen nicht rot sind sondern schwarz.
Na gut das haben wir jetzt glaube ich auch ausdiskutiert so hat noch jemand ein,
ein beitrag taler du hast ja noch.
Ja äh den den den rauswerfen zur späten stunde.
Hier sind wir schon so weit.
Nee nicht ganz ja,
vielleicht würde ich würden wir uns das thema open data open science für einen anderen mal aufheben weil da kann man so ein bisschen bisschen mehr ausschweifen,
und vielleicht kann ich da dann noch mehr von von berichten was ich aber ganz cool fand,
die zeit gibt immer so ein campus journal raus,
und da gibt es jetzt gerade einen neuen wegweiser promotion,
entscheidend planen durchhalten und es hat mich sehr angesprochen kann man kostenlos auf der website bestellen.
Weil du gerade in der phase bist.
Ich bin immer noch bei dem durchhalten also.
Beim durchhalten das ist schon der letzte teil.
Ja also ich bin ja schon relativ lange in quasi wissenschaftlichen publikationen und in dem promotions zwecklos auch wenn ich meine promotion offiziell quasi anfang zweitausendsiebzehn angefangen habe,
und ich habe jetzt die feste deadline dass ich quasi im oktober diesen jahres mein promotions verfahren eröffnen muss was so viel heißt ist meine publikation meine peer-review journal publikation müssen angenommen sein,
bei den peer-review journals also bei irgendwelchen die auf bestimmten listen stehen und akzeptiert sind und jetzt nicht,
laut meiner promotions ordnung ein hauptautor paper und zwei co-autor paper das heißt autoren haben ja immer so listen von von.
Papern haben listen von autoren der der ganz vorne steht ist normalerweise der der es geschrieben hat der der ganz hinten steht ist der verantwortliche,
die dazwischen haben so anteilig und das heißt ich muss bei zwei papern co-autor sein also irgendwo in der mitte stehen,
bei einem muss ich vorne stehen sozusagen,
wenn ich diese drei veröffentlichungen wenn die angenommen habe angenommen wurden schreibe ich noch eine doktorarbeit über diese drei paper,
und diese doktorarbeit muss sich quasi im oktober diesen jahres einreichen und damit ist dann offiziell das produktionsverfahren eröffnet,
was so viel heißt wie die wird formal geprüft die wird review und geprüft dann kriege ich irgendwann feedback dazu dann muss ich zu dem feedback stellung nehmen und dann kriege ich irgendwann vielleicht einen verteidigungs- termin ein mündlichen,
dann muss ich mündlich diese arbeit noch mal verteidigen und wenn ich das auch bestanden habe dann ist sich sozusagen die promotion abgeschlossen.
Da bist du doktor tala.
Dann bin ich irgendwann doktor taler vielleicht hoffentlich.
Und wie weit bist du mit den drei peppers also hast du da schon welche.
Co-autoren paper sind nicht das problem.
Hauptautoren schafft vielleicht.
Das ist halt so ein bisschen genau das frustrierende es hat sich jetzt aus verschiedenen gründen ewig gezogen,
ich schreibe ich schreibe gerade an zwei papern eins ist jetzt schon bei dem ersten journal eingereicht,
das wird vermutlich abgelehnt weil wir zu hoch gegriffen haben aber wir wollten mal gucken ob es geht,
das heißt das wird nach feedback dann in einem anderen journal eingereicht feedback überarbeitung und das zweite da sitze ich jetzt dran das muss halt auch demnächst eingereicht werden.
Was meinst du damit zu hochgegriffen.
Das würde ich auch gerade fragen.
Journals haben ja so einen impact faktor das heißt ganz oben ist zum beispiel nature oder science,
veröffentlichen extrem wenig sind extrem viel gelesen extrem viel zitiert und dementsprechend haben die einen sehr sehr hohen journal impact- factor.
Das heißt wenn du da bist hast du es geschafft.
Wenn wenn du da bist dann hast du spätestens danach also da als erste autor hast du spätestens ein jahr.
Deswegen hast du dir gesagt du hast heinz und nature kommt überhaupt in frage was anderes schreibe ich gar nicht erst an.
Nee nee zum beispiel das iphone go paper ist bei ich glaube nature gelandet so also die,
da bin ich noch weit entfernt aber trotzdem gibt es halt relativ hoch angesehene journals die sich auch sehr aussuchen was sie publizieren und die art von wissenschaftlicher mache ist halt nicht,
also ist halt spannend für einige aber das ist halt auch relativ technologisch und deshalb ist das nicht so gut für bestimmte neurologische journals zum beispiel,
für deren audience das halt da nicht so relevant ist aber versuchen kann man's ja und.
Also wenn ich das richtig verstehe,
dieser prozess mit deinem hauptteil noch angenommen zu werden der läuft grad oder der steht noch bevor oder gerade das was.
Ich habe zwei chancen,
eine ist jetzt in processing das zweite paper ist vermutlich einfacher zu publizieren und das ist jetzt sozusagen das backup paper,
das heißt ich habe ich habe einen plan a das wäre cool wenn der durchgeht falls ihr nicht durchgeht habe ich einen plan b.
B auch nicht durchgeht dann kannst du es schon mal vergessen mit dem termin.
Ja aber das ist unwahrscheinlich also dann reiche ich es in irgendeinem popel journal ein was das definitiv annimmt,
es ist halt so es ist dann ist dann schade um die arbeit aber das paypal muss halt angenommen sein und ich,
also gerade so medizinische technologie oder medizinische themen in technologischen papern werden halt gerne genommen,
ich möchte halt gerne mit einem technologischen thema in ein medizinisches paper weil das weil die ansprüche einfach höher sind und weil die,
ja meine aber auch die des journals an die science die dahinter steht,
und da lesen es halt auch mehr mediziner an die ich mich ja eigentlich primär richten möchte,
also da wird auf die eine oder andere art und weise knappen ist halt nur arbeit und muss irgendwie gemacht werden und,
so promovieren ist halt einfach gerade nebenberuflich,
ein schönes hobby.
Ja und kannst du jetzt tipps aus dieser dieser schrift herausziehen oder kam es alles zu spät.
Nee ich finde ich fand's tatsächlich extrem schön ich habe es gestern erst gesehen und mal drüber geguckt das schöne ist halt das ist wirklich von anfang bis ende von möchtest du wirklich promovieren und,
über durchhalten da haben die halt teilweise auch erfahrungsberichte von was ist wenn es mit dem betreuer nicht läuft so,
kann man krisen gespräche führen oder erfahrungsberichte von personen die ihre promotion einfach abgebrochen haben und erfahrungsberichte von
leute die ihre promotion halt irgendwie trotz schwierigkeiten dann wieder durchgezogen haben und das ist einfach so eine schöne,
das beleuchtet viele schöne seiten auf eine gut lesbare einfach konsumiert ihre art und weise.
Und was ich halt zum beispiel auch ganz gut fand also gerade jetzt so ich habe schon auf konferenzen meine arbeit vorgestellt,
aber da ist halt auch so ein abschnitt so ok wie publiziert man jetzt einfach oder wie stellt man,
seine seine arbeit auf konferenzen vor wie network- mann,
wie läuft das ein theoretisch so ab mit einem paper zu publizieren,
und man sieht halt auch ganz gut wand so ja herzlichen glückwunsch du hast es geschafft du darfst jetzt wirklich mal durchatmen so das ist das ist gut was du geschafft hast.
Das ist glaube ich auch nicht zu zu verachten weil wenn man,
einfach sich so lange stress macht und auch permanent irgendwie diesen diesen unterschwelligen druck die ganze zeit über drei vier fünf sechs jahre das ist schon nicht,
unbedingt einfach und dadurch dass das ganze auch noch kostenlos ist und im öffentlichen internet zu finden
wollte ich das mal so ein paar leuten ans herz legen die entweder überlegen zu promovieren oder die selbst in der promotion sind und sich,
mal neue sichtweisen holen wollen und ich finde es auch ganz wichtig zu sagen dass es total okay ist nicht zu promovieren,
oder dass wenn man feststellt die promotion ist nichts für ein das auch einfach abbrecht das ist überhaupt nicht schlimm.
Ich habe mir das auch gedacht ich promovieren nicht.
Als ich gehört habe dass der doktortitel teil meines namens wird habe ich gesagt nee ich will dich doch da seht lack heißen.
Aber ich bin immer sehr froh über über diese titel felder in irgendwelchen formularen wird ja dann immer gefragt so was was ist denn der titel und ich trage immer spezial experte ein und dann kriege ich immer schöne e-mails so,
sehr geehrter herr spezial experte tim.
Sehr schön finde ich es auch mann frau doktor und ich kann dann einfach doktor thaler.
Das gibt's auch.
Ist es denn so ja ja das wird einfach zusammengeworfen man frau doktor professor als auswahlfeld keinen.
Eure hoheit fehlt da noch.
Kannst du gerne mal vorschlagen vermutlich wenn man es bei schlecht geforderten frontend- irgendwie im code anpasst landet dann auch einfach.
Einfach beschweren einfach beschweren ich habe hier ich wollte ihr kontaktformular auswählen aber leider.
Rede mit der ich.
Ja also weder durchlaucht noch eure hoheit ja.
Noch gender.
Eure majestät hochwohlgeboren nichts dergleichen alles nicht dabei frechheit was hältst du denn von so politikern die so ihr doktor abgeben müssen.
Wenn's gerechtfertigt ist klar also in manchen,
in manchen wissenschaften ist es glaube ich extrem schwierig eine doktorarbeit zu verfassen,
wo nicht plagiat vorwürfe rauskommen also es geht dann halt immer,
um um den level aber gerade wenn man jetzt zum beispiel einen geschichte hat man hat mit so vielen literatur und quellen und nachweisen zu kämpfen,
das ist da glaube ich viel viel einfacher ist in ungewollt oder gewollt zu plakatieren,
als jetzt zum beispiel hier mathe weil da hast du dann halt.
Von der summe her würde das stimmt aber das kann ich mir jetzt nicht vorstellen dass jetzt so plugin wie heißen diese plugin blogs oder nee ist diese diese auswertung software guten guten plack.
Die planks halt.
Okay in so einer geisteswissenschaftlichen deskriptiven arbeit lieber wenn du sowas historisch also ich,
ich kann das selber historiker da musst du dann schon aber auch mal einen bereich haben wo du mal mit deiner these auf den tisch kommst,
da musst du auch deine gedanken haben und das sind die zentralen dann,
entwickelst du natürlich wie komme ich denn auf diese verrückte idee und dass du dann natürlich ein mittelteil hast wo relativ viel
dinge quasi als quellenangabe drin sind aber das problem ist ja nicht quellenangabe drin zu haben sondern diese guten platz zeigen ja quasi wo man gewissermaßen.
Tate nicht als solche gekennzeichnet hat.
Genau und ich finde das ist also wirklich relativ einfach das zu drehen es gibt so eine grauzone dass man sagt oh jetzt habe ich schon so viele in,
in anführungsstrichen direkter zitiere jetzt mache ich mal ein vergleich,
da und da weil ich das irgendwie zusammengefasst habe das darf natürlich auch nicht überhand nehmen aber ich finde situationen regeln ehrlich gesagt doch relativ klar verständlich und.
Ich verteidige auch in keinster weise jetzt irgendwie die personen die ihre ihren doktortitel abgeben müssen,
es sollte nicht passieren ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es in manchen wissenschaften einfacher passiert als in anderen,
und ich habe jetzt das problem dass ich mit meiner doktorarbeit ja eigentlich meine eigenen paper zusammenfassen muss das heißt ich muss aufpassen dass ich mich selbst nicht platziert hier weil das wird auch angerechnet,
das würde dann genauso mir auf die füße fallen.
Was war denn jetzt für dich der.
Eigenen paper.
Entschuldigen sie kann ja nicht eine eigene arbeit original abgeben die quasi sich stützt auf die arbeiten die aber keine doktorarbeiten sind diese schon vorher geschrieben.
Ich muss ich muss mit meiner doktorarbeit auf meine paper referenzieren die zusammenfassen muss aber aufpassen dass ich halt zum beispiel nicht gleiche worte phrasen wiederverwenden,
plagiat und so und das ist lustig aber jetzt auch hoffentlich kein großes problem.
Und wann ich meine doktorarbeit quasi ist doch die aufgabe den bisherigen wissens also auf basis des bisherigen wissensstand eine originäre eigene erkenntnis noch mit drauf zu setzen,
ja was war denn jetzt für dich wichtig dass du dir diesen promotions stress auferlegt hast.
Purer masochismus nein ich habe halt ich ich arbeite ja in der medizinischen forschung ich bin software-entwicklerin,
algorithmen entwickelt habe neue technologien erforscht hatte nebenbei durch meine,
und durch meine zusammenarbeit mit der charité eh schon wissenschaftlich veröffentlicht und dachte mir eigentlich möchte ich jetzt gerne mehr forschen mehr wissen mehr lernen,
und ich hatte die hoffnung,
das wunschdenken dass ich mir irgendwie mehr zeit für tatsächlich so den wissensaneignung nehmen kann,
aber jetzt nur so bedingt geklappt hat weil mit mehr als vollzeitjob ist schon ein bisschen schwierig.
Es ist nicht so dass du quasi weil du kein doktortitel hast von diesen anderen mediziner nicht ernst genommen wird weil du willst ja und deswegen.
Ändert der doktortitel auch nicht beide sein und von medizinern unter umständen nicht ernst.
Für sie doktor.
Für sie doktor thaler,
nee überhaupt nicht der anspruch sondern also es hat sicherlich irgendwie mit reingespielt dass ich einfach gucken wollte ob es geht.
Ich denke es geht für mich mir war bewusst was für konsequenzen das mit,
und die habe ich jetzt halt genommen mit halt wenig freizeit keinen urlaub wenig soziale kontakte.
Krass wenig medienkonsum wie wir.
Es ist.
Oder ohne diesen podcast wäre sie schon vollkommen sozial verarmt.
Nein ohne die letti.
Und diesen podcast.
Wahrscheinlich exponentiell erhöht mein mein meine interaktion mit menschen ne also ich versuche da die waage zu halten aber.
Bist du offensiv sogar prokrastinations-killer weil dann würde man sich ja quasi dann so in medienkonsum stürzen und selbst das hast du heldenhaft abgemetert.
Prokrastinieren aber nur solange es meine meine to-do-liste erlaubt.
Also das ist aber es ist das mal so ein richtiger harter prokrastinations-killer definition des.
Nee also es ist schon sehr sehr viel selbstdisziplin muss an der stelle auch einfach und,
deshalb ich möchte es überhaupt nicht glorifizieren was ich tue ich würd es niemand anderem empfehlen,
ich kann nur sagen dass ich es bis jetzt noch irgendwie durchhalte aber mein mein doktortitel habe ich auch noch nicht,
mal gucken wann ich den kriege ich habe jetzt gerade von einer kommilitonin gehört die hat jetzt insgesamt fast anderthalb jahre verbracht von einreichung zu feedback zu,
sie darf irgendwann verteidigen.
Musst du diese papers immer nochmal dem jeweiligen magazin so ein bisschen anpassen musste immer nochmal wieder zu trinken oder kannst du quasi das einmal scharf stellen und dann geht das nature blablabla.
Du darfst du darfst veröffentlichungen ja sowieso nur einmal einreichen also das paper was jetzt gerade in der form existiert reichst du einmal ein.
Und dann ist es tot selbst wenn's abgelehnt ist.
Nee wenn du's ablehnst musst du also.
Wenn es abgelehnt wird.
Wenn es abgelehnt wird dann ist das thema im prinzip wieder offen wir nehmen halt dann das feedback von dem journal gucken was wir anpassen wie wir es adaptieren und bringst zum nächsten pepper.
Das ist quasi so eine rotation.
Ja ja verbesserungen interaktive verbesserung ich bin gerade bei meinem einen paper in total nummer neun.
Wow okay aber ich gebe es hat ein bisschen was so einblick in drehbuch entwicklung und da ist das ähnlich da gibt's dann so das ist jetzt die endgültige fassung nummer acht.
Nee nee ja so ist es halt leider aber,
oktober und so und jetzt habe ich es offiziell im öffentlichen internet erwähnt dann jetzt habe ich noch mehr druck von außen das tatsächlich irgendwie zu.
Jetzt muss es laufen.
Muss es laufen ah ich bin gespannt.
So schnell bekommen.
Bestimmt also die größte unsicherheit ist jetzt halt journal also papa muss angenommen werden eines der beiden,
was ganz cool war die charité hat halt so eine statistik ambulanz das heißt,
mit statistischen fragestellungen wenn man nicht weiß wie man seine daten analysieren soll,
kann man dort einmal einfach hingehen und sich halt so eine kostenlose beratung als doktorandin oder forscherin holen und das ist extrem cool vor allem weil ich,
diese woche mal da war für einen diffizilere problem und wollte mich einfach mit jemandem unterhalten der bisschen mehr ahnung hat als ich oder einfach mehr praxis und die haben einen kompletten raum nur voller statistik bücher,
komplette kleine bibliothek ja.
Da gehst du steil.
Auf jeden fall auf jeden fall so.
Da kannst du doch mal prokrastinieren.
Die haben ja ein praktikum angeboten und ich meinte ist gerade schwierig aber danke.
Tja gut ich glaube jetzt kommen so langsam ans ende dieser sendung oder.
Zum abschluss.
Trinkst du nicht immer musik hintendran darfst du das überhaupt zum abschluss.
Dürfen es kommt ein kosmos die diskussion machen wir jetzt nicht auf.
Wir können hier nicht.
Tun oder nicht.
Wir können hier nicht rausgehen ohne jetzt nochmal einfach.
Aber was ist mit terry jones.
Der ist auch schon tot der hat den hatten wir am anfang wir haben am anfang ganz darüber.
Nehmen wir billy ins fadenkreuz nicht einfach nur spielen dann müssen wir das auch thematisieren.
Erst thematisieren und für die ganz vielen da draußen die wie ich bewusst er,
bewusst erst wahrgenommen haben als ich hier irgendwie nachrichtensendung gehört habe die hat irgendwie so und so viel sachen abgeräumt und ich setze bitte einiges kommt jetzt dauernd irgendwie so rein geschwebt das scheint ein interessante musikalisches phänomen zu sein da muss ich mal so reinhören
und dann war es so ein so ein bisschen so eine synapsen explosion die bei mir da so stattgefunden hat plus natürlich dieses monster,
diese monster hookline die inzwischen,
wo ich gelesen habe dass sie dann auch als als klingelton inzwischen die deutsche natürlich nervt weil also das ist ja quasi
jammer vor verdächtig.
Also damit auch alle dir folgen können schließlich das mal für die leute die unter dem stein gelebt haben.
Ja hallo tala aufwachen.
Mir ging's auch ein bisschen ähnlich allerdings wurden meine
meine meine meine aufmerksamkeit wurde schon schon ungefähr vor einem jahr drauf gelegt ich hab's dann nur etwas versäumt dem hinterherzugehen also wer ist bitte eine spiele eine verhältnismäßig junge
sängerin und songwriterin die jetzt glaube ich gerade im dezember achtzehn geworden ist,
die vor zwei einhalb jahren ungefähr ihren ersten song in die öffentlichkeit getragen hat per upload auf soundcloud.
Das war dann sozusagen schon ihr aller erster hit und ich zögere kurz weil zwischen diesem moment mit der titel im fall entfallen ist,
verdammte axt fällt mir gleich wieder ein und,
ja dann ging das irgendwie schnell rum und es dauerte nicht lange und sie war so ein bisschen die der geheimtipp und das ding.
Das ist sie jetzt nicht mehr wenn so zwei alte dudes über so eine junge künstlerin sprechen hier dann scheint es ja so in im mainstream angekommen zu sein.
Ja also ich meine ich bitte sich die.
Das ist.
Sie hat jetzt fünf krimis gewonnen das ding ist durch ne.
Und jetzt sogar in der metaebene wird drüber gesprochen also.
Ja ich hätte jetzt zwar vergessen das war der song jetzt fällt's mir wieder ein,
also es gab so ein erstes album das besondere an ihr ist jetzt sie macht das alles mit ihrem bruder zusammen finja unter dem namen ist ja bekannt,
also nur dem namen ist ja bekannt und ja die,
sitzen halt irgendwie in ihrem kinderzimmer und haben halt diese songs gemacht so soweit jetzt erstmal alles nichts besonderes gab's ja schon oft so ah ja okay junge leute machen musik wovon redet ihr eigentlich.
Das ist ziemlich verschwurbelte komische musik also das könnte jetzt.
Kann man nicht zu programmieren.
Hier in berlin ist jetzt gerade cdm festival für adventure music wenn quasi wenn ich dort jetzt irgendwo ins,
berghain gehe heute oder morgen da kannst du eine sie genauso ein eck mit genauso kuschel musik mit ein bisschen beats drunter und einer fehlen stimme blubbert über autodieb,
das fand ich das das tolle das ist so komplett avantgarde und du sagst auch so ein bisschen kinderzimmer productions weiß.
Was man aber nicht merkt also es ist hochgradig gut produziert.
Außer dass meine bose box bei manchen frequenzen so in die knie geht.
Ich habe,
auch mit komponisten schon gesprochen und meinten alle so ist wer außergewöhnlich gut wäre es hat ja auch gerade in der hinsicht noch preise abgeräumt das ist also auch rein produktionstechnisch
sehr gut sei,
und das macht natürlich apple auch doppelt stolz weil es macht irgendwie mit damit haben sie irgendwie alles zusammen gezimmert soweit ich das weiß,
na ja dann ist das auch wir ihr zweites album rausgebracht und das ding hat jetzt irgendwie alles abgeräumt und nächste abteilung,
sie macht jetzt.
Dreiundzwanzig der dreiundzwanzigste bond der wann rauskommt.
Vielleicht dezember ich weiß nicht.
Ok ich dachte das wäre schon irgendwie bekannt weil sie jetzt bekannt gegeben haben dass sie den soundcheck dazu macht keine ahnung.
Guck mal starttermin ich weiß aber nicht wie der titel heißt und dreiundzwanzig konnte aber funktionieren.
Ich gucke gerade denn hier die filme filmer film filme die tolle liste.
Das erste videospiele meine güte.
Sorry das ist ja alles.
Medienkompetenz muss.
Ja entschuldigung entschuldigung northeim mit daniel craig der fünfte und wohl auch der letzte mit daniel craig.
Nimm mal an ja.
Ist das hier die release premiere einunddreißigster märz zwanzig zwanzig äußern on come.
Der stall der soll jetzt in den nächsten tagen schon es ist für mich in den nächsten tagen.
Nein am einunddreißigsten märz wenn du das so nennen möchtest dann ist das so.
Das ist gesichert ich hätte jetzt gedacht.
Das steht in der wikipedia.
Somit ist es gesetzt.
Gibt es eine unabhängige quelle dazu ich hätte jetzt gedacht dass das der starttermin natürlich im november oder dezember dazu zu normalen.
Startet no time total james bond blablabla deutschlands weiter april.
Geschockt hatte die b den song schon fahrt ich dachte ihm würde jetzt nach dieser geschichte.
Nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein das haben die vorher schon bekannt gegeben dass sie das tun wird.
Das weiß ich auch.
Ja also sie wird wie gesagt dass das geht bei ihr jetzt schon.
Ich sage dir der ja dass der name ist mehr durch verschiedene zusammenhänge und da war natürlich auch das ist die neue bond interpretin aber deswegen bin ich neue bond interpretin haue ich mich noch nicht gleich in eine suchmaschine rein und will dann alles erfahren es.
Ja aber wenn du mal schaust wer bisher so die bond titelsong gemacht hat ist das natürlich wirklich eine sehr illustre riege in der sie sich da jetzt gerade wieder findet,
mal ganz davon abgesehen dass jetzt gerade rihana und taylor swift und so weiter irgendwie die preise abgenommen hat.
Zurecht genau fehlen nämlich auch und ihr ganzen kulturbahnhof ihr denkt ihr müsst euch mit popmusik nicht auseinandersetzen er hört ja jetzt mal rein und dann habt ihr eure eigene meinung mir auch egal,
so also ich sag,
wir machen jetzt hier mal langsam aber sicher schluss gregor schön war es mit dir wieder.
Dankeschön für die einladung ciao.
Schön ne so ja tada mit dir was auch schön.
Hier haben wir dir auch tim.
Ach das ist halt ein herz und eine seele hier alle leute vielen dank für eure unterstützung vielen dank fürs zuhören wir hören uns in zwei wochen wieder und dann geht's weiter,
bis dann tschüss.
Hey.
Marie.
Machst du auf,
da hinten auch nochmal hinten ans weggefahren,
gut macht's gut,
jungs,
sport,
küche,
scheine seiner seiner seiner seiner.
Ich bin schon,
ja
kein dvd,
na na na na na na,
hier haben wir,
wo steht like.